Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Prittlav
und es ist Samstag der zwanzigste Februar zwanzig einundzwanzig und ein Tag
später als gewohnt nehmen wir Corona Weeky auf mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Ja, es war ein bisschen viel los und äh die Woche war auch wieder voll mit tausend Meldungen und wir hatten so unsere Schwierigkeiten hier den Überblick zu bekommen, deswegen haben wir erstmal auf den Samstag geschoben.
Seht es uns nach.
Ja dafür haben wir glaube ich auch eine Menge auf der Liste, ähm die es so zu besprechen gibt.
Ja, stimmt, oder? War viel, oder?
Ja, definitiv.
Ja. Ich habe äh schönes Bild auf Twitter gefunden, was jemand gepostet hat.
Englisches äh ich weiß gar nicht, sieht aus wie so ein Zeitungsausschnitt und äh.
Dry and Steat.
Pestilences, Purch Fromour Lands. Soundsmove Valliant in Haroy.
Und ich habe mich gefragt, wie man das denn irgendwie gut auf Deutsch übersetzen kann. Bin total dran gescheitert.
Und habe dann irgendwie mal Twitter gefragt, was die denn eigentlich so meinen und da kam dann irgendwie ein paar schöne Vorschläge. Schwierig, dieselben Pathos da reinzukriegen, aber der Gewinner war dann.
Bis die Pest sich einst verzieht,
bin und leiblich ihre Miete von ihrem schönsten. Grüße an Cosmar, das war sehr hübsch,
Ja, fangen wir mal vielleicht mal an mit ähm.
Es kam relativ viel, ich kann unmöglich auf alles eingehen, vielleicht mal so zwei, drei Sachen, die ich ganz interessant fand, zunächst einmal äh gab's relativ viel Rückm
Meldung zu unserer Klage über Tirschenreuth und noch so ein paar andere Landkreise, die wir so
ja, so ein bisschen gescholten haben dafür, äh dass sie die Situation nicht so recht in den Griff kriegen.
Hatten wir ja schon öfter und ich glaube, was man an der Stelle nochmal betonen muss und das kam natürlich dann auch in den Kommentaren, dass ähm ja, das ist halt alles Grenzregion nach Tschechien sind.
Basti schreibt, für Tirschenreuther ist es einfach sehr schwierig, überhaupt auf brauchbare Institzen zu kommen, wenn die Institanz ein paar hundert Meter weiter über die Grenze über eintausend steigt. Gerade die bayerischen Landkreise an der tschechischen Grenze sind massiv von den tschechischen Arbeitskräften abhängig.
Komplette Pflege und auch größeren Teile des Krankenhauspersonals. Dort kommt aus Tschechien.
Allein Tirschenreuth hat jeden Tag mehrere tausend Grenzübertretungen nur aus dem angrenzenden Landkreis, wo die Leute reihenweise infiziert sind, aufgrund des grundsätzlichen Wunsches der EU, Grenzen offen zu halten.
Auch weil Tschechien bislang kein Mutationsgebiet war, hatte der Landkreis auch wenig Handhabe.
Man hat es deswegen in Bayern zunächst mit Pendler Tasting versucht, allerdings haben sich daran besonders die jüngeren Generationen nicht gehalten.
Ja nachvollziehbar und zeigt natürlich auch die Schwierigkeiten in einem engen vernetzten Europa hier Maßnahmen zu ergreifen.
Wobei letztlich natürlich die Situation Grins überschreiten. Also es ist immer die Frage, welche Grenzen, auf welche Grenzen schaut man einfach, wir haben's halt hier mal mit starken Grenzen zu tun. Genauso haben wir aber auch schon geklagt, dass halt auch die Grenzen zwischen den.
Landkreisen, also das Phänomen hat man ja eigentlich überall,
im Prinzip äh dasselbe Problem haben, dass äh wenn's mal Fortschritte hier gibt, das sofort durch entsprechende Infektionsketten aus benachbarten Landkreisen wieder überschattet wird.
Was ich genau äh hast du dir die Situation in Tschechien nochmal genauer angeschaut.
Nein, es ist schlimm. Ähm.
Ja
In Tschechien macht halt jetzt dritte Welle.
Sind sie voll dabei. Ich habe jetzt gar nicht mal geguckt, aber äh das hattest du ja letztes Mal schon angedeutet, dass ich das abzeichnet, dass sie das nicht so richtig in Griff kriegen.
Ich schaue nochmal schnell.
Sich eigentlich jetzt entwickelt hat in Tschechien, im Vergleich zu Deutschland, ja, das sieht nicht gut aus, das geht auf jeden Fall weiter.
Nach oben und das auch relativ steil ist. Derzeit aktueller Stand hat Tschechien eine Institanz von achthundert.
Pro Tag.
Das ist also mal so.
Pro Million.
Genau äh genau.
Sind also umgerechnet dann irgendwie sieben Zehntel davon.
Also ich sag mal so das Zehnfache knapp neun bis zehnfache von von Deutschland und wir sind ja hier schon nicht besonders glücklich mit der Entwicklung. Ja also was soll man dazu sagen.
Ja, nur hier klingt so roh als könnte man da gar nichts gegen tun.
Ähm aber,
möchte ich halt jetzt so einfach nicht glauben, dass man da jetzt nichts gegen tun könnte. Es ist irgendwie,
einfach so sein muss, sondern ähm.
Ja manchmal ist es, ich glaube, wir haben's da dann auch mit einer Kombination zu tun aus Gesundheitswesen und Grenze, wenn man mal sagen muss, haben das unser äh.
Gesundheitswesen, die Krankenhäuser einfach mal ähm auch einen, ja, nicht zu unterschätzender Verbreitungsherd sind und zwar.
Einfach weil es zu wenig Personal gibt, weil halt dort Personal ja nicht ausreichend geschützt ist
ähm dann sind so Dinge wie Pendelquarantäne, halt Gang und Gäbe sind, dass die Leute irgendwie sind zur Arbeit müssen eigentlich in Quarantäne müssten, aber
dann die Quarantäne darin besteht, dass ich gefälligst zu Hause von der Familie zu isolieren haben und ansonsten halt
sich auf dem Weg zur Arbeit möglichst von Leuten fernhalten müssen. Allerdings durchaus auch den ÖPNV benutzen dürfen so
und äh dann ja arbeiten sie halt
in der Klinik, obwohl sie eigentlich, wenn sie nicht in der Klinik arbeiten würden, normale Personen wären zu Hause sitzen müssten und äh in Quarantäne sein müssten, ja
und.
Testen, zum Testen haben die Krankenhäuser, das haben wir glaube ich auch schon mal erwähnt, haben die Krankenhäuser halt auch keine Zeit so, man könnte ja jetzt einfach mal,
jeden vor der Arbeit einen Schnelltest verpassen oder einen Schnelltest nach Hause mitgeben, den machen die Leute dann äh vielleicht.
So morgens nach einem Aufstehen oder so und je nachdem fahren sie dann zur Arbeit oder nicht wieder schnell Test äh äh ausfällt, aber äh ja für so pragmatische Lösungen äh.
Dass wir halt nicht flexibel genug und dort wo das tägliche Testen versucht wurde, wurde es dann wie oft nach einer Woche aufgegeben, weil der Dokumentationsaufwand einfach zu hoch war für das Ganze
und ähm.
Dann auch zu viele Leute ausfielen und so, deswegen hat man das, lässt man das mit dem Testen in den Krankenhäusern lieber das macht nur schlechte Laune.
Ja, dann braucht man sich natürlich nicht zu wundern, wenn dann diese beiden Dinge zusammenkommen da im Grenzgebiet.
Ja. Ja und meine.
Wir werden uns da glaube ich in dieser Hinsicht mehrfach noch wiederholen. Das ist halt das alte Lied, wenn man halt beschließt, nichts dagegen zu tun, dann,
wird's halt nicht besser und dann wird's halt auch nicht kontrollierbarer
ne? Also harte Maßnahmen sind halt einfach erforderlich und sicherlich müsste man dann an der Stelle eben auch die Grenzen einfach zu machen oder in diesen Pendlerverkehr eben ganz anders kontrollieren. Und sonst entsteht ja auch einfach kein Druck für eine Verhaltensänderung.
Gut. Dann ähm gab's noch, wir hatten ja kurz äh gesprochen über diese ganzen Technologien, die.
Ähm jetzt zum Einsatz gebracht werden müssen, um diese MRN A Impfstoffe zu produzieren,
und in dem Zusammenhang haben wir auch über Mikrofluidik gesprochen und du hattest dieses tolle Ventil äh erwähnt. Ich kam in dem Moment auch nicht äh drauf, heißt,
Tesla Ventil. Also dieses rein.
Hatte ich nicht gesagt, dass von Tesla kommt.
Das weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau. Wir wurden auf jeden Fall auf den richtigen Namen nochmal hingewiesen, dass vielmehr in dem Moment dann auch äh ein wollte ich hier an der Stelle nochmal.
Gebracht haben. Dann hatten wir noch irgendwie darüber gesprochen, dass
Impfdrängler irgendwie über die mehr berichtet werden sollte, da kommen wir glaube ich heute eh nochmal zu, wenn's um diesen Astrazinika-Impfstoff geht. Da kam dann der schöne Verweis auf den Kartoffelbefehl.
Der Kartoffelbefehl äh,
war nämlich die Bezeichnung für die Anordnungen äh und Verordnungen Friedrichs des Zweiten von Preußen an die Beamten seiner Provinzen, denen er sich bemühte, den Anbau der Kartoffel in preußisch Provinzen durchzusetzen. Äh ja,
sind dann also wirklich Leute durch die Gegend gelaufen, sogenannte Knollenprediger, die dann irgendwie den Leuten äh eingebläut haben, das ist mit der Kartoffel gar nicht so eine schlechte Idee. Dann wurde sie später auch populär.
Muss man den Leuten jetzt auch in dem selben Maße äh klar machen dass Impfstoffe ganz hilfreich sind.
Die Kartoffel hat es ja wirklich erstmal schwer in Frankreich gab's glaube ich auch ein absolutes Kartoffelverbot, gab's sogar
Todesstrafe auf Kartoffelanbau oder sowas.
Hat aber ein Arzt, hat dann ähm.
So bei Hufe halt dann die Kartoffel eingeführt äh unterschiedlich zubereitet und nachdem dann halt ja am Hof äh die Leute gefallen äh daran hatten, wurde dann das Verbot irgendwann gekippt.
Hat alles geändert. Pommes ändert alles.
Pommes ändert alles, genau. Ja.
Und äh ja überhaupt war die Kartoffel dann schuld an ganz vielen politischen Umbrüchen auch. Wahrscheinlich auch. Äh ja, plötzlich war zu viel oder waren genügend Kohlenhydrate da, das äh die.
Deutlich mehr Bevölkerung,
ernährt werden konnte, was dann auch so ein bisschen möglicherweise zum äh ja schnelleren Rückgang des Feuerlismus auch mitgeführt hat und zu einer Hungersnot dann anschließend auch
irgendwie, jawohl.
Daraufhin ja ist, gab's eine Bevölkerungsexplosion, aber die Kartoffel konnte dann doch nicht ganz so viel mithalten. Egal, wir schweifen jetzt ein bisschen ab, aber Kartoffeln, Kartoffeln sind toll.
War auch, glaube ich, ja, was die Wenigsten auch das, dass Kartoffeln im Gemüse ist und war, glaube ich, das Gemüse des Jahres, was,
zweitausen.
Kartoffel war das Gemüse des Jahres.
Mhm. Es gibt jedes Jahr ein ein Gemüse des Jahres zweitausenddrei, genau, die Kartoffel war das Gemüse des Jahres zweitausend.
Dann gucken wir mal, wer so Impfstoff des Jahres wird.
Ich hab da ja ein äh Kandidaten. Aber lassen sie jetzt mal erstmal über die Zahlen reden. Wir haben ja schon einiges befürchtet letzte Woche. Inwiefern sind denn unsere Befürchtungen eingetreten.
Ja ähm es entwickelt sich eigentlich alles genau wie erwartet. Das äh kann man so sagen, die.
Der R-Wert ist langsam angestiegen beziehungsweise der Rückgang der Neuinfektion.
Hat sich verlangsamt und ist eigentlich in den letzten sechs Tagen praktisch äh zum Stillstand gekommen. Also wir hatten jetzt nur noch.
Fünf Prozent.
Rückgang äh gegenüber der äh Vorwoche im Sieben-Tagesschnitt und das aber auch nur, weil äh ja es nur,
jetzt Insekt in den letzten sechs Tagen gestoppt hat. Ich nehme an morgen oder übermorgen spätestens werden wir auch äh ja,
vielleicht schon deutschlandweit Wiederanstiege sehen leichte.
Also in einigen Bundesländern ist es natürlich jetzt schon so, sonst würde sich das ja nicht entsprechend entwickeln. Wer sind denn so die böse Wichter? Können wir vielleicht gleich nochmal draufkommen.
Ja gut, wenn.
Die Zahlen, ne?
Erwähnt hast, also sechs Länder haben jetzt so steigende Raten, Thüringen, Sachsen-Anhalt, Bremen,
Niedersachsen, Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und Nordrhein-Westfalen ganz leichten mit einem Prozent, aber Anstieg ist Anstieg äh so. Ja,
ähm und die Zahl der Länder hat auch ja zugenommen, in denen es jetzt Anstiege gibt. Berlin hat.
Noch fallende Zahlen, zehn Prozent Rückgang, aber es waren halt auch schon mal mehr. Also es ist überall eigentlich fast verlangsamt, sich der Rückgang.
Ja
Und man auch schon sagen ähm kein Land wird in den nächsten zwei Monaten irgendwo in die Niere sicherer Institzen für Lockerungen kommen bereits jetzt bei dem,
Trend von heute und,
Wissen verschlechtert sich dieser Trend sogar. Das heißt ähm eigentlich um das auch vorwegzunehmen rechnet praktisch jeder mit einer neuen Welle im März.
Schließen sich alle unserer Meinung an sozusagen.
Und ja, ich wie gesagt und bundesweit liegt der jetzt bei null Komma neun sieben bis es praktisch eins, vor allem, wenn man die Testzahlen auch noch äh mit dazu nimmt,
ist die Zahl der Tests wieder um.
Ja vier Prozent zurückgegangen, vier Komma acht Prozent gegenüber der Vorwoche und das heißt effektiv äh sind wir jetzt schon bei eins oder über eins. Ähm.
Mit dem RW. Also.
Trotzdem ist sie die positiven Quote nochmal gesungen.
Das äh ist äh ganz gut, allerdings äh muss man eben auch,
sehen, dass wir die leider immer auch nur mit einer Woche Verspätung äh praktisch,
kriegen. Ich habe jetzt nochmal in die neuen Tabellen äh habe ich nochmal das genaue Datum bis wann eigentlich einschließlich äh sagen diese Testzahlen gelten und da kann man sagen, sind wir.
Fünf, sechs Tage immer.
Hinterher ähm oder sind die Testzahlen fünf bis sechs Tage hinterher gegenüber den Neuinfektionszahlen.
Und auf deinen Wunsch, ich weiß nicht, ob du's schon gesehen hast, habe ich jetzt die Testzahlen auch mit in den Graf eingearbeitet und die positiven Quote und so.
Nee, habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Ist jetzt noch unübers.
Wollt's gerade sagen. Ah ja, schön. Ja.
Ich habe dann jetzt so äh Bilder gemacht, wo ich dann jeweils einen der Grafen hervorgehoben habe, damit man den ein bisschen besser sehen kann.
Ah ja, sehr schön. Packe ich äh wie immer äh noch zusätzlich mit ins Blog, da könnt ihr irgendwie reinschauen und euch mal die.
Verwirrenden Kurven anschauen zugegebenermaßen nicht die übersichtlichsten sind, aber sich so ein bisschen reinfuchs, kann man da schon ein bisschen was rauslesen, aber es ist für uns auf jeden Fall immer ganz hilfreich, um einfach die Sachen schneller in Kontext äh setzen zu können.
Ja, also wie sieht's denn aus? Jetzt äh ganz allgemein. Also wir haben ähm sieben Tage Schnitt von siebentausendzweihundertfünf.
Neuinfektionen pro Tag.
Ja, genau. Das sind so fünfzigtausendvierhundertsechsunddreißig pro Woche. Also fünfzigtausend pro Woche. Ja.
Und ähm bis jetzt auch nicht wenig würde ich sagen.
Und bei den Toten hatten wir noch nicht erwähnt, da ist der Rückgang noch eher ungebrochen, es auch zu erwarten, dass das jetzt noch zwei Wochen so,
weiter geht, aber wir haben da jetzt einen sieben Tage Schnitt von vierhundertzweiundzwanzig pro Tag
oder auch zweitausendneunhundertvierundsechzig Menschen sind in den letzten sieben Tagen gestorben an Corona.
Und da können wir erwarten, dass das noch,
zwei Wochen lang sinken wird in die Gegend auf zweihundert bis zweihundertfünfzig pro Tag dann wahrscheinlich auf dem Niveau so verharren plus minus
und dann äh Ende März wahrscheinlich wieder ansteigen. Nass.
Ist das, was wir leider nach derzeitigen Informationsstand erwarten können. Hm.
Ja und auch bei der Positivrate, wie gesagt, die ist jetzt.
Auf sechs Komma vier sechs Prozent gefallen und das hatten wir zuletzt ähm so Ende November.
Ende Oktober. Ende Okt.
Ende Oktober, Anfang November, ja. Genau, ja. Ende.
Ende Oktober, Anfang November hatten wir diesen Wert überschritten und äh den haben wir jetzt erreicht. Ja und.
Also zum Beginn des des des Lokdownlights sozusagen, ja? Also das ist jetzt äh gerade mal so der Punkt, den wir erreicht haben. Natürlich mit einem anderen Trend, aber wie wir ja schon gehört haben, der Trend ist halt nicht besonders toll.
Interessant ist auch, wenn man sich jetzt den Grafen von der positiven,
Quote anschaut. Das ist halt so dieser Violette Verlauf. Dann findet man da gar nicht diese wilden,
Ausschläge äh die wir bei den Neuinfektionen hatten. Wir haben ja so eine total kaputte.
Oder die unsere Welle sieht ja total kaputt aus, andere Länder, da geht's halt hoch und dann geht's wieder runter
den Meistern bei uns ging's irgendwie hoch, dann wieder ein bisschen runter, dann,
irgendwie über Weihnachten piek äh dann zwischen Weihnachten und Silvester brachen sie total ein, um dann Anfang Januar wieder hochzuschießen. Also so ein richtiges Zahlenchaos,
da kann man halt davon ausgehen, auch wenn man sich die Positivquote jetzt anschauen, dass das halt durch diese Änderung im Testregime und Weihnachten
und dass das halt nur erfassungsbedingt war, dass man wahrscheinlich auch hm eigentlich eine schöne Kurve,
rausmachen könnte, die nicht so wind wild gezackt ist. Gut nicht, dass das wichtig wäre.
Aber sollte sich jemand gefragt haben, warum die so komisch aussieht? Das ist alles eine Frage von Meldung.
Und vor allen Dingen doch, also eigentlich ist es schon ist so eine zackige Kurve, ist halt auch echt völlig unnötig dramatisch, ja. Äh ich meine, du hast dann halt,
wenn, wenn man's jetzt als Sportkommentator so äh oder als jetzt ja, wie wir als Corona Kovit-Kommentator da hast du halt diesen gewaltigen
Anstieg im Oktober so bis Mitte November.
Um dann plötzlich so ab Mitte November so einen leichten Rückgang zu haben, so alle schöpfen Hoffnung, aber das war das jetzt, das war jetzt schon der Piek
und dann plötzlich so warm schießt's auf einmal wieder nach oben, mein Ingenie, was ist denn jetzt passiert? Wieso schießen denn die Zahlen? Jetzt so nach nach oben
um dann halt ja wieder krass zu fallen und denken alle, oh ja, jetzt haben wir es irgendwie überstanden. Nein, dann geht's plötzlich wieder nach oben, ja. Ich mein
Das ist ähm einfach unnötig dramatisch. So und macht alle Leute nur irre,
macht natürlich auch jede Vorhersage erstmal in dem Bereich, wenn wenn es so wild hin und her springt weiß ja auch keiner, wovon und hinten
oder oben und unten. Wenn in Wirklichkeit aber äh diese Kurven,
oder diese diese Sprünge gar nicht echt sind, wir machen uns da einfach dann ja mit unserer ganzen Datenerfasserei machen wir uns da einfach äh.
Unnötig verrückt oder unnötig Hoffnung. Also wir verwirren uns unnötig. So.
Jetzt hast du ja in deiner Risikotabelle Änderungen vorgenommen, das sollten wir vielleicht nochmal erwähnen. Viele Leute schauen da ja auch mit rein und äh erkundigen sich so über den den Stand der Dinge
die Tabelle ist ja mehr so eine Datenbank als äh jetzt wirklich so eine
hübsch designte Geschichte zum Einbauen in allen Webseiten. Aber du hast jetzt quasi die Unübersichtlichkeit noch ein bisschen erhöht, indem du noch ein paar Spalten eingefügt hast.
Ja, ich habe noch vier Spalten hinzugefügt
Bisher ergab sich ja durch das Ranking auch so eine gewisse Prognose das Ranking selbst basiert ja ähm auf einer Prognose, so wo wird es in einer Woche äh stehen, äh weil ähm
die Erfassung ja äh immer mit zehn Tagen Verzögerung läuft. Die Zahlen ist natürlich,
aktuelle Risiko ergibt sich quasi aus einer Vorhersage ähm von zehn Tagen in die Zukunft so ungefähr, aber.
Dass man nirgendwo so richtig explizit außer in der Risikozahl drin und war ja jetzt das Thema Institzen äh auch immer wichtiger wurde, habe ich jetzt,
zwei Spalten eingebaut, die auf Basis des aktuellen RWEs oder des aktuellen Wochentrends ähm,
die Institanz in vier Wochen und in acht Wochen äh voraussichtlich wiedergeben. Klar äh.
So lange Zeit kann man eigentlich nicht äh wirklich vorhersagen, aber es ist mehr, okay. Wenn es jetzt so bliebe, dann wären wir äh.
Ja
bei der entsprechenden äh Institanz, also für Deutschland werden wir dann noch, weil es noch zurückgeht, jetzt sind wir bei fünfundsechzig und werden dann in vier Wochen bei dreiundfünfzig neun und in acht Wochen, bei vierundvierzig, sieben.
Wo das sind, sagen die mal zu gucken, ja denn eigentlich ist es ein bisschen Veranschaulichung des Erwertes, wenn.
Genau, das wollte ich nämlich auch gerade sagen, weil das finde ich eigentlich an der Stelle auch extrem hilfreich. Vor allem, wenn man sich dann mal die anderen Extreme anschaut, auf der positiven Seite derzeit der
bist Performance äh Landkreis hätte ich fast gesagt, dass Performance Bundesland ist Baden-Württemberg
Die haben derzeit eine Insidenz von siebenundvierzig eins.
Wohlgemerkt, wir beziehen uns hier immer auf diese Tabelle, ne? Und Pavel hat ja ein paar abweichende Berechnungs ähm Schemataler drin, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt genau immer die Zahl, wie man sie beim RKI liest
weil hier auch spätere Meldungen noch mit berücksichtigt werden. Aber nehmen wir einfach mal das Beispiel, siebenundvierzig eins
würde also in Baden-Württemberg jetzt alles so bleiben wie es ist. Derzeit haben die so einen Ehrwert von null Komma neun, hieße das in vier Wochen, wenn man bei dreiundzwanzig vierundacht Wochen wäre man bei elf Komma sechs. Das ist so der der Best Case eigentlich. Der halt.
Saarland ist eigentlich also Saarland äh es wäre langfristig äh die sind haben zwar jetzt noch eine höhere Institenz, das heißt, die würden sie nächste Woche nicht überholen, deswegen sind sie im.
Ja ich hab grade nicht nach nach RWE sortiert genau richtig, du hast Recht, also dann korrigiere ich.
Beziehungsweise hin.
Ja. Also Saarland würde sogar äh ja in acht Wochen also wahrscheinlich irgendwann in sechs Wochen wie könnte das Saarland äh jetzt äh sogar sicher äh.
Erste Lockerungen vornehmen, wenn es dort so bliebe.
Mit leider nicht zu rechnen ist, aber das ist sozusagen das Optimum. Auf der anderen Seite.
Hätten wir dann eben da, wo es derzeit am schlechtesten läuft, Bremen, die noch vierundsiebzig Institz haben werden in äh acht Wochen dann schon wieder bei zweihundertfünfzig.
Und so extrem kann sich das dann halt auswirken, auch wenn der RWE,
nur bei eins Komma null neun liegt, ne? Auf der anderen Seite ist halt schon null Komma acht zwei schon äh relativ gut wie jetzt im Saarland, nur sehen wir das halt nicht überall.
Oder anders ausgedrückt, wenn man's jetzt mal für Deutschland nochmal allgemein nimmt, so wie es derzeit läuft, bringt uns das nirgendswo hin. Das ist ja sozusagen die Zahl. Außerdem hast du ja noch zwei weitere Spalten, dann dazu gebracht. Das muss man vielleicht auch nochmal erklären,
Tage bis sieben steht da und Tage bis drei.
Bezieht sich dann eben auf diese konkrete Inszenz, vielleicht kannst du ja nochmal kurz herleiten, wo du diese sieben und diese drei hernimmst.
Mhm. Ja, also die sieben ähm
ist zu der Wert, wenn man sich einfach die Zahlen für die Institution in gesamt Deutschland anguckt, äh hat
ist, äh, wenn die Gesamtizidenz in Deutschland einmal über sieben war, äh ist sie nie wieder ohne Lokdown äh unter sieben
runtergegangen und ähm sieben beziehungsweise ja neun äh,
ist halt auch eine gute Zahl äh um,
erste Lockerungen zu machen, sie ziehen unterschreiten, das ist auch die Institanz, wo wir in der ersten Welle die ersten Lockerungen gemacht haben ähm,
und äh sozusagen bei neun wollen wir sie beschlossen. Ich glaube bei sieben sind sie dann in Kraft getreten,
Plus mit den neuen Mutanten ähm ja ist es jedenfalls so, dass so die Institanz von sieben, ich meine, man kann jetzt diskutieren.
Ob das jetzt acht, neun, zehn oder
fünf oder sechs wären aber sieben äh war einfach so ein Wert, den ich ganz handhabbar fand und den man eben auch zweimal tatsächlich finden
äh kann und die drei war dann die Institanz, bei der wir dann am meisten gelockert haben im im Sommer,
so bei der Unterschreitung. Ja und deswegen gibt es auch zwei Spalten, die dann jetzt äh einfach mal berechnen, wie lange es dauern würde
bis zu einer Institanz von sieben und wie lange bis zu einer Inszenz von drei. So.
Genau
Also wenn wir jetzt mal für Deutschland äh schauen, Tage bis äh zu einer Institenz sieben werden dreihundertvierunddreißig Tage und eine Institenz bis ähm
drei werden vierhundertzweiundsechzig Tage, also man kann halt sagen.
Würde es so bleiben, wie es jetzt ist, müssten wir den aktuellen Zustand noch ungefähr eine Jahr beibehalten.
Und wir gehen davon aus, dass es halt noch ein bisschen schlimmer wird und äh bis man sich so richtig frei machen kann, also die selben Lockerungen wieder lostreten könnte vierhundertzweiundsechzig Tage, dass es dann halt irgendwie ja eins Komma drei Jahre. Also es.
Ja, ist natürlich hypothetisch, aber diese Zahlen äh also waren vor ein paar Tagen,
sahen die halt noch ganz anders aus. Da waren wir noch im Bereich von zwei Monaten. Äh, also wir hatten ja, wir hatten, glaube ich, achtundfünfzig Tage für Deutschland bis Institanz sieben.
Vor wenigen Tagen war das halt noch nicht so. Und äh ja.
Im Prinzip kann man festhalten, dass man mit einem ordentlichen Lokdown innerhalb eines Monats hm äh die Zahlen ja auf ein zweihundertstel bringen kann.
So, also kann's äh im im Prinzip kannst du fast von jeder Institanz, die wir hatten, wenn mit einem richtigen Loktown in einem Monat auf eine Institanz von unter drei runterkommen.
Ja, den hatten wir jetzt nicht. Und den haben wir auch immer noch nicht und den werden wir auch nicht kriegen, weil sich da einfach politisch nichts bewegt. Stattdessen haben wir Öffnungsdiskussionen und Lockerungsdiskussionen und das ist einfach, ja, der falsche Weg.
Na ja.
Denn Muttertionen, Muttertionen, Muttertionen.
Kriechen an uns heran und äh ja wie zu erwarten war.
Verbreitet sich vor allem der sogenannte englische Virusvariante, also diese B eins eins sieben Variante, relativ stark in Deutschland.
Teilweise auch schon die Südsüdafrikanische Variante, was ich besonders beunruhigend finde, denn da wissen wir ja, da wird's dann mit den Impfstoffen schon so ein bisschen kritisch
bei B eins eins sieben ist es halt nur die erhöhte Transmissibilität und theoretisch auch noch die erhöhte Todesrate, die sich daraus dann ableiten lassen kann.
Ähm, was hast du denn da so für einen Blick drauf.
Na ja, das RKI hat ja ähm in dieser Woche.
Erstmals Zahlen veröffentlicht äh was die neuen Varianten in Deutschland,
angeht und ja da sind wir jetzt äh also bei den sogenannten Vox, bei den besorgniserregenden Varianten.
Ähm ja, sind wir jetzt bei vierundzwanzig Komma eins Prozent.
Anteil in äh den Test, davon sind zweiundzwanzig Komma acht Prozent mh B eins eins sieben,
und die B eins drei fünf eins, also Südafrika eins Komma drei Prozent und dann äh die,
P eins mit null Komma eins Prozent. Das sind so die drei Varianten auf die äh,
die jetzt gefunden worden sind, für die es Zahlen gibt.
Ja und wenn man sich dann die Entwicklung anguckt äh Anteil jetzt dieser Konzern, KW zwei waren's zwei Prozent.
Eine Woche später drei Komma sieben, dann fünf Komma eins, zehn Komma acht,
vierundzwanzig Komma eins jetzt in KW sechs, das heißt es hat sich ungefähr jede Woche verdoppelt bisher. Die äh Zahl, das heißt ähm,
Ja. Also äh Mitte März äh,
sind die neuen Varianten bei uns eigentlich durch. Also werden wahrscheinlich noch ähm,
Also Ende des Monats ähm ja äh werden hier die fünfzig Prozent überschritten haben. Wahrscheinlich, wenn das so weiter geht sogar.
Eigentlich in der nächsten Woche werden wir so irgendwo zwischen vierzig und fünfzig landen und in der übernächsten Woche werden äh.
Ja B eins eins sieben und Konsorten die Mehrzahl aller Infektionen ausmachen.
Und dann mit erhöhten R-Werten eingehen. Also wir haben jetzt sozusagen drei Faktoren. Wir haben neue Mutationen, die äh höhere Ansteckbarkeit ergeben. Wir haben Lockerungen,
Schulöffnung, wenn auch nur im frühen Grundschulalter, wenn auch mit Masten, wenn auch mit entsprechenden
Vorsichtsmaßnahmen, Schulteilungen und so weiter. Das mag sich dann wieder und wird sich auch in jedem Bundesland natürlich wieder unterscheiden, aber das bedeutet auch wieder mehr Bewegung, mehr mehr Möglichkeiten, noch irgendetwas auszutauschen
da können dann eben die Mutationen auch entsprechend zuschlagen und werden sie dann wahrscheinlich auch und damit ist dann halt einfach ein R-Wert unter eins
eher unwahrscheinlich. Ja und damit müssen wir dann irgendwie leben, leider wieder,
Es ist nicht schön.
Ja. Naja gut, die, ich meine, wir wissen ja aus England, dass man auch die neuen,
Varianten sehr wohl bekämpfen, reduzieren oder deren R-Wert effektiven RWT unter eins,
bringen kann. So also unmöglich ist es nicht und im Moment gibt es ja schon ich sage mal so eine, auch so eine äh,
Koalition der hartnäckigen würde ich sagen die zwar jetzt ganz schön im Feuer steht, aber gibt's halt schon jetzt würde ich sagen auch in der Politik gerade so 'ne
Gruppe von Leuten, die erbittert dagegen hält im Moment, also ne.
So Lockerungen angeht um jeden Meter kämpft gerade. So und dazu gehört auch die Kanzlerin würde ich sagen.
Ciao.
Die Frage ist nur, was bringt's, ne? Also er ist schon mal ganz gut, das im Bundeskanzleramt vor Orte zu wissen, aber bisher haben wir ja immer gesehen, dass die Bundesländer dann äh immer wieder einknicken und
und diesen Weg nicht mitgehen, um dann später wieder festzustellen, dass er auch nicht besser geworden ist dadurch.
Meine Befürchtung ist ja, dass wir wieder irgendwie ein,
wie ein Hickhack äh äh haben werden und
ja die Zahlen so ja langsam steigen wieder so eine so zitterpartiemäßig und wie wir da,
Weder richtigen Lokdown äh noch irgendwie einen eine wichtige Explosion.
Wobei meine wahrscheinlichste Prognose, die ist, dass die zweite Welle die dritte Welle, also die nächste Welle.
Etwas höher sein wird, aber dafür nicht so breit, also nicht so lange dauern wird.
Weil ich denke wir nicht den Fehler machen werden.
Und äh so graduell wie im November reingehen und dann gibt's halt auch keine Weihnachtszeit und so und das ist auch so oft die Erfahrung.
Aus anderen Ländern, die uns wellenmäßig ein bisschen voraus sind, dass da äh dann ja.
Die Wellen tendenziell wenn eine neue kommt höher werden und wir starten ja auch von einem viel höheren Ausgangspunkt jetzt die Welle auch als die letzte.
Ja. Das sind die Gründe. Bist du noch da.
Ja, ich bin noch da, ich denke gerade drüber nach und ähm frag mich jetzt aber trotzdem, warum du meinst, dass es schneller vorbei geht, dann wieder die Welle. Weil wir da besser reagieren werden.
Ja, ich ich glaube, es wird dann äh äh ich glaube Psychologie.
Dass wir dann äh einfach ja dann schneller reagieren werden, aber äh.
Gut muss man sie in Deutschland macht ja.
Irgendwie auch immer so ein bisschen spezielle Korrummen, wenn man das so mit anderen Ländern vergleicht. Denn Dänemark ist übrigens ein ganz guter, ganz gutes Vergleichsland auch, wenn man sich mal angucken möchte, weil die,
ungefähr hm so,
ja relativ vergleichbare Zahlen mit Deutschland haben so von der Größe und von Timing her, sie laufen halt ganz gut mit nur.
Ja das bei denen die Zahlen nicht so kaputt waren über Weihnachten so ähm sind dann die.
Haben da so eine schöne runde Kappe und dass sie halt dann einen ordentlichen Lokdown gemacht haben und dann jetzt schneller und tiefer reduziert haben von einem wesentlich höheren Niveau äh als wir das äh gemacht haben.
Ja, aber derzeit auch nur unwesentlich besser dastehen als wir, ne.
Mhm. Aber halt äh muss man sagen, ähm,
wahrscheinlich sind die äh stehen sie deutlich besser da, weil wenn du mal die Positivquote von Dänemark äh anguckst, die testen halt, ich glaube ungefähr zehn Mal so viel wie wir.
Und ja.
Die ist deutlich niedriger. Mega.
Die sind bei was? Null Komma irgendwas oder.
Null Komma drei null Komma vier so in dem Bereich während wir halt bei sechs Komma fünf irgendwie sind.
Das heißt, du kannst äh einfach sagen, du davon ausgehen, dass unsere Dunkelziffer.
Quote äh wahrscheinlich fünfzig Prozent, hundert Prozent,
größer ist als die in Dänemark, also in Dänemark kann man sagen, ist das ziemlich nah dran an ähm dem, was an Infektionen äh passiert, während bei uns wir halt nach wie vor keine Ahnung, immer noch zwischen
sagen zwischen fünfzig und dreihundert Prozent sich außerhalb unserer Erfassung äh abspielen könnten.
Ja, na gut, dann hoffe ich.
Dass du Recht hast, dass wir da schnell reagieren, aber die Frage ist natürlich warum müssen wir dann erst reagieren, wenn man auch jetzt schon äh reagieren könnte, weil das ist ja im Prinzip jetzt schon absehbar. Ich meine, wir sind ja.
Eigentlich jetzt genau in der selben Situation, wie wir das im Oktober oder im September waren, alle Zahlen sprechen dafür, dass es jetzt bald wieder nach oben geht und wir quasi jetzt unmittelbar vor der dritten Welle stehen. Alle sagen das.
Genau. Mhm.
Zahlen sagen das, die Experten sagen das so die wissenschaftliche Gemeinde scheint sich da einig zu sein.
Und uns passiert nix. So, stattdessen wird über über Friseure äh müssen geöffnet werden und Schulen müssen geöffnet werden,
So ja natürlich müssten die ihn irgendwann mal wieder geöffnet werden, aber dann schafft doch bitte auch die Voraussetzungen dafür, dass die geöffnet werden können und das tun wir nicht und deswegen.
Verlieren wir ja wieder Zeit. Also ich meine, warum sind jetzt die Maßnahmen, die schon lange in Place.
Ja was was glaube ich die wenigsten verstehen ist dass praktisch zu jeder Zeit oder in jeder.
Pandymiephase das Richtige ist ein.
Sofortigen maximal harten Logdown.
Durchzuführen. Die Zahlen in kürzester Zeit zu senken und dann graduell zu lockern, wenn man eben bei einstelligen Institzen.
Angekommen ist so. Und es ist egal, ob sich die Zahlen im Anstieg befinden oder.
Äh fallen aber nicht schnell genug fallen die beste Variante ist immer sofort und maximal hart. So, das heißt eigentlich hätten wir.
Ja, bräuchten wir ähm eigentlich ab morgen äh nochmal einen richtig harten Blogdown für die nächsten. Zwei bis vier Wochen.
Und äh dann könnten wir auch lockern. Aber ja, wird wohl nicht kommen.
Wird wohl nicht kommen, genau. Und dann.
Dauert's noch länger alles. Also Ostern kann man glaube ich schon mal vergessen, so. Da wird irgendwie nichts besser sein. Das hätten wir theoretisch schaffen können, wenn solche Maßnahmen ergriffen worden wären, aber das wird jetzt wieder verspielt sein.
Und da wir nicht davon ausgehen können, dass vor Juni, Juli durch die Impfung nennenswerte Verbesserungen eintreten, wenn überhaupt,
dann ist halt eigentlich der Sommer schon weitgehend im Eimer.
Ja gut für wird man sehen, ähm aber.
Meine Vorhersage war ja, dass wir irgendwie.
April, Mai, zumindest, äh, wieder im Shotdown verbringen werden.
Monat oder so war das glaube ich mein meine Vorhersage.
Als das mit den ja mit B eins eins sieben begonnen hat war das eigentlich so relativ klar und.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Wie oft man das eigentlich wiederholen soll und muss und vermutlich gut für die meisten Zuhörer hier äh da ja predigt man zum Chor eigentlich.
Wahrscheinlich ja.
Wir wollten's ja nur mal gesagt haben,
Du hast halt einen schönen äh Tweet äh Kette rausgehauen, die äh ganz gut resoniert hat, äh habe ich so den Eindruck ähm
das kann man vielleicht jetzt da nochmal so äh hinten anstellen. Und zwar hast du dich äh bist du bist du äh in das Virus geschlüpft.
Ja
The world acording to saasko zwei würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, mir kam halt in der letzten Woche so der Gedanke auch, dass ja.
Virus.
Ein ziemlich hilfloses Geschöpf äh ist und sich eigentlich in einer komplett prekären Situation befindet und dann,
mal überlegt, äh wie denn die Welt aus Sicht des Virus eigentlich aussieht, äh so und,
Das Problem ist ja äh dieses Virus ist nirgendwo willkommen. So, das wird halt
überall gejagt, außerhalb des Körpers kann es nicht existieren, da zerfällt es so, ähm, da ganz maximal ein paar Tage, aber meistens Stunden oder oft sogar nur Sekunden überleben,
im Körper.
Hat auch nicht viel Zeit, weil dann kommt irgendwann nämlich das Immunsystem und greift es an und vernichtet es. Das heißt, damit dieses Virus überhaupt existieren kann, braucht es eben immer neue Wirte und
Normalerweise innerhalb von einigen Tagen oder spätestens zwei Wochen und sonst ist halt zu spät. So und dann,
ist es auch noch so, dass um jetzt zu so einem neuen Wirt zu kommen, muss es halt erstmal aus der Zelle, in der es zusammen,
in der es dann geboren wurde
irgendwo in eine Körperflüssigkeit gelangen und die muss dann auch noch in der Ecke des Körpers sein, wo dann die Flüssigkeit mit einem Luftstrom mitgerissen wird
außerhalb des Körpers gelangt. So und dann sitzt dieses arme Virus
jetzt in irgend so einem winzigen Flüssigkeitstropfen und fliegt halt durch die Luft wie in so einer Raumkapsel, vielleicht noch mit ein paar Geschwistern drin,
aber diese
kleinen Raumkapseln, die haben halt keinen wirklichen Antrieb oder so und deswegen stürzen die meisten einfach ab und fallen auf den Boden und
dann ist auch ziemlich schnell vorbei, wenn es irgendwo hinfällt nur so ganz wenige davon am Glück irgendwo zu landen, wo dann vielleicht jemand rechtzeitig,
draufpackt und.
Aufhebt und dann äh auf irgendeine rettende Schleimhaut äh von sich aufbringt, so aber das passiert halt ganz, ganz selten so. Und.
Die anderen, ja, wie gesagt, die meisten stürzen ab, aber so ein paar haben halt das Glück, die sind in einem Tropfen drin, der entweder
richtig gut beschleunigt wurde, der richtig Speed hat, weil jemand den ausgehustet oder ausgenießt hat und der dann mit der richtigen Dynamik äh unterwegs ist oder,
er hat das Glück, äh, in einem Tropfen zu sein, der so klein ist äh und die Wetterbedingungen stimmen, dass er halt längere Zeit in der Luft schwebt.
Und so halt dann eingeatmet wird, sodass dann sich äh halt äh.
Die Viruskopie dann sich im Schleim der Nase oder des Rachens oder der Lunge gemütlich machen kann, beziehungsweise nicht wirklich gemütlich machen,
Es ist zwar schon ein Hauptgewinn wie ein Lottobis da einzukommen aber ähm so.
Einfach da rumschwimmen ist nicht, weil die müssen jetzt irgendwie wieder in eine Zelle kommen und in dieser diesen Schleimhäuten sind auch lauter
chemische und biologische Kampfstoffe, die dem Virus das Garaus machen wollen, so Defensine und ähm andere Stoffe, die einfach das Virus so.
Greifen und ja es hat also 'ne begrenzte Zeit sich irgendwie jetzt an der Außenhaut von der richtigen Zelle festzuklammern. Ähm, so.
Entsprechenden Rezeptoren und dann die Schleuse zu hacken und dann äh ja äh sein Erbgut in die äh Zelle äh zu packen
und äh ja und mit Glück hat dann dieses diese Rena hat dann auch den Transport überlebt und.
War's dann auch die richtige Rena und hatte nicht zu viele Kopierfehler so ja und dann äh fängt die Zelle halt an die richtigen Bauteile zu produzieren und dann müssen sich nur noch diese Bauteile
Kann man sich so vorstellen, sind halt Proteine, so ziemlich lange Moleküle aus Aminosäuren und die,
falten sich halt ganz wild und haben dann eben so verschiedene Andockstellen, so wie Lego nur halt nicht nur mit runden Noppen, sondern vielleicht auch mit dreieckigen oder mit,
ja ganz verschieden geformten, individuellen Noppen. Und dann schwimmen die Bauteile für das neue Virus, schwimmen jetzt in der Suppe einfach rum und bauen sich dann.
Mehr oder weniger alleine zusammen. Also wenn sich dann die passenden Teile mit ihren Andruckstellen nahe kommen eventuell muss da noch so ein drittes Teil, so ein Enzym, so ein Werkzeug noch dazu, aber grundsätzlich rasten die Teile dann
ziehen Sie sich elektrisch an und rasten dann irgendwann ein und mit 'n bisschen Glück kommt dann am Ende 'n neues Virus mit Hülle und mit RNA drin raus und auch so ein
Ding ist, die Viren, ähm also Corona Viren.
Sehen halt nicht gleich aus, äh sondern die haben halt schon so können in ihrer Größe ein bisschen variieren und auch eine unterschiedliche Anzahl von ähm.
Spikes äh haben und so ähm was eben an diesem, ja,
Prozess liegt, dass es halt in Teilen gebaut wird, die sich dann dann zusammenfinden. Na ja. Also das war halt so,
das Ding also dieses Existenz als Virus ist halt eine echt prekäre Angelegenheit so nirgendwo hat,
ist man wirklich heimisch oder findet Ruhe, man wird ständig gejagt, muss tödliche Luft überwinden so und wird halt überall von der Umwelt angegriffen so von der korrosiven Atmosphäre, also es ist halt ja eher wie ein.
Fremder Planet so die Außenwelt. Und insofern sagen ja.
Würde das das Virus, wenn es denken und sprechen könnte, sagen vielen Dank für eure Toleranz, Hilfe und Geduld, so ohne eure logische Unterstützung und Gastfreundschaft könnte ich ihnen dieser Feindseeligenwelt nicht lange existieren.
So und ja und äh und auch ich meine, dieses Virus könnte gar nicht so weit reisen, ja? Also
so dank äh nur dank uns, weil wir halt schnell um den Globus reisen, steht dem Virus überhaupt die ganze Welt offen. Bis eben auf so ein paar Virusfeindliche Länder, die das Partout nicht reinlassen und nicht tolerieren, aber ansonsten,
Ja, ist ja sind wir eigentlich äh vergleichsweise virusfreundlich, würde ich sagen, weil sonst ähm,
kämen das Virus von alleine einfach nicht klar, wenn wir nicht. Ähm tolerant genug wäre.
So viele Möglichkeiten, das zu stoppen, aber keine wird genutzt und das äh im ausreichenden Maße und vor allem regelmäßig permanent wird diese Brücke gebaut
dass das Virus dann rüber äh purzelt und und,
die einfach die Bereitschaft nicht oder die Fähigkeit nicht der gesamten Gesellschaft einfach diesen Luftraum zu entziehen.
Zumal es im Schnitt, wie gesagt, mindestens zehn bis zwanzig Kontakte braucht, bis halt des Virus es tatsächlich schafft.
Jemand neues zu finden und also man braucht schon eine Menge Kontakte damit man auf einen R von eins kommt, die das jetzt haben.
Ja und,
Nein, die zweite Sache, die ich mir überlegt hatte so bisschen auch als Gedankenexperiment die Zahlen äh sind ja.
Verdammt hoch, so und wir haben ja jetzt.
So ein Großteil der Weltbevölkerung und dann ich glaube auch Teile der Tierwelt nachdem zu so einem riesigen
Kulturmedium zu einer großen Petryschale für Saaskoff zwei Virus-Evolution äh gemacht und da habe ich mich gefragt, na ja, was kann denn da eigentlich
jetzt kommen, was können wir denn erwarten, wenn wir halt Infektionen weltweit auf einem Niveau haben
wie äh das jetzt äh aktuell ist und ähm.
Was äh wir jetzt haben, äh ist aber einen Bündel ganz unterschiedlicher Maßnahmen. Das Virus kann sie ja nicht frei verbreiten, sondern wir üben quasi evolutionären Druck aus und.
Wenn es dann zu Mutationen kommt, dann,
Ja wählen wir durch unsere Maßnahmen quasi die Varianten aus dienen Vorteil
haben oder benachteiligen alle anderen. So und dann natürlich grundsätzlich, wenn wir jetzt Kontakte reduzieren, dann hat.
Deliktieren wir halt ansteckendere Varianten. So die halt dann äh ja weniger Kontakte brauchen und äh.
Würden wir jetzt alle sagen, bisschen mehr Abstand halten, dann äh werden Viren selektiert, die auf größere Entfernung infizieren, also wenn wir sagen, okay, niemand kommt sich jetzt näher als anderthalb Meter oder so, dann äh
werden Viren, die auch bei zwei Meter ganz gut schaffen, haben dann den Vorteil,
Durch unsere Masken selektieren wir natürlich Viren, die besonders gut Masken umgehen können. Also zum Beispiel die dann wieder durch Schmierübertragung besser sind, also sich sich dann irgendwie länger
irgendwo halten oder,
generell höhere Viruskonzentration dann aufweisen, weil mit den Arios Eirosolen ist es nämlich so, dass,
gerade die ganz kleinen Tröpfchen, die sich besonders gut in der Luft halten, aber bei typischen Viruskonzentrationen oft.
Mh gar keine Viruskopien enthalten. So, das heißt ähm.
Frohe Viruskonzentration hilft also auch wirklich gerade die kleinen Tröpfchen und jedes von den kleinen Tröpfchen dann halt auch mit Viruskopien zu füllen. Ja dann durch.
Testen und isolieren, haben dann natürlich Motationen besonderen Vorteil, die jetzt irgendwie unsere Tests umgehen.
Oder die wenig Symptome machen, wenn wir halt nur symptomatische Personen testen und isolieren, dann haben natürlich
ja die Asymphomatischen einen richtigen Vorteil und
durch das Impfen und das ist natürlich lange bekannt, äh selektieren wir dann Viren, die dann die Immunisierung umgehen, also wenn sich halt dann auch Escape äh Motationen,
so und mal sagen na ja es.
Was ist denn dann mit dem Impfen wäre es dann nicht besser, irgendwie jetzt mal unabhängig von den Folgen die Bevölkerung durchinfizieren zu lassen, weil dann selektiert man natürlich Mutationen, die wiederum frühe Reinfektionen ermöglichen, die also,
quasi ähm ja äh versuchen irgendwie der natürlichen äh äh Immunität äh zu entkommen.
Ja ich denke ähm sozusagen erstmal die die Sicht.
Nicht ganz ganz interessant, also welche welche Art von Selektionsdruck wir wir ausüben und insofern können wir erwarten, dass überall wo wir Druck ausüben
möglicherweise eine Mutation, die genau diese äh Maßnahme umgehen kann, äh dann besondere,
Vorteile hat und.
Wenn man jetzt drauf guckt OK wie funktioniert das denn jetzt im.
Virus, also welche, welche Funktionen hat denn so ein Virus und äh wenn's jetzt zu Mutationen äh äh kommt, ähm.
Ja wie welche funktionalen Auswirkungen haben jetzt äh äh die Montation und zum Beispiel kann es Mutationen geben, die einfach die Hülle,
oder die Spikes stabiler
machen. Das heißt äh dass sie halt äh ja länger außerhalb des Körpers äh dann ansteckend bleiben, weil sie nicht so schnell von ähm.
Ja vom Sauerstoff angegriffen werden oder von von.
Anderen Chemikalien und Temperaturstabiler sind und ja auf Oberflächen halt länger Infektions bleiben.
Was wir auch ja hatten, dann wiederum Motation am Spike äh Protein.
Speziell die Anlogstelle kann ja dass die Dockingfähigkeiten verbessern und,
damit dann die Ansteckungswahrscheinlichkeit erhöhen wenn 'ne Kopie erstmal in den Körper gelangt ist. Die liegt glaub ich jetzt so bei eins zu zehn eins zu zwanzig Größenordnungsmäßig das heißt.
So von zwanzig Viren, die es in die Schleimhaut schaffen, ähm ja, schafft's dann meist nur so ungefähr eine in die Zelle, Größenordnungsmäßig und wenn das natürlich besser wird, ja, dann reichen halt weniger.
In Kopien im Schnitt. Besonders spannend dann in dem Zusammenhang. Mh dieser.
Der Kopiermechanismus, mit dem halt neue Viren äh hergestellt werden und vor allen Dingen die RNA kopiert äh wird, kann sich dahingehend verändern, dass entweder.
Schneller kopiert wird oder genauer kopiert äh wird. Das heißt, es kann sich auch selber die Mutationsrate noch verändern, das heißt, das Virus kann auch stabiler oder instabiler äh wirken,
und ähm genauso können sich dann äh auch noch bestimmte äh Resistenzen.
Gegen bestimmte,
ähm ja Stoffe auf Schleimhäuten, also diese Defensine, die ich glaube ich schon mal erwähnt habe, also ein sich höhere Defensivresistenz äh sodass äh die halt in Schleimhäuten auch länger überleben,
aber ähm ja.
Der und dabei biete ich noch äh auf eine Sache gestoßen, die ich besonders spannend fand und,
insbesondere auch eine Erklärung dafür bietet, warum die Krankheit oft so unterschiedlich verläuft, wie sie verläuft. Und zwar.
Hat saß äh Kopf zwei eben auch Gene um das Immunsystem auszutricksen. Das haben,
viele andere Viren auch, eigentlich auch fast alle, aber äh die meisten anderen Viren äh haben äh einen wesentlich,
schlaueres oder mehr Sofisticated System um.
In das zu tun und zwar muss ich da jetzt ganz kurz nochmal ein bisschen ausholen.
Der ein oder andere äh weiß es äh vielleicht, aber wir haben ja ähm zwei Arten von Immunsystemen, die sich auch.
Ja, äh, nacheinander rausgebildet haben und die auch zusammenhängen, nämlich das sogenannte angeborene Immunsystem und das Erworbene Immunsystem. Das angeborene äh Immunsystem.
Ist halt sofort,
da und verfügbar und hat halt so ein ganzes Arsenal an Stoffen, Enzymen, um.
Giftige oder fremde Stoffe zu erkennen und sofort zu attackieren anhand von ganz vielen Markierungen und auch an an Besonderheiten, äh wie sie,
versuchen dann eventuell die Zelle äh aus der Balance zu bringen, also falls,
angeborene Immunsystem sofort verfügbar attackiert von Sekunde eins an, äh, wenn das Virus in der Schleimhaut landet, äh so ähm ja,
arbeitet das angeborene Immunsystem und ähm,
viel Immun im Immunsystem läuft auch für durch Signalisierung ab, also wenn so eine Zelle jetzt feststellt hier, hm äh mir ist jetzt übel, ähm ich glaube, ich habe.
Einen Virus, dann ähm werden eben verschiedene Stoffe ausgeschüttet, unter anderem eben sogenannte Interverone.
Auch die
anderen Zellen Bescheid sagen, dass sie doch bitte zur Hilfe kommen oder auch aufpassen sollen, weil Viren jetzt gerade unterwegs sind und gefälligst auch äh jetzt äh ja Alarm machen. So,
und dann gibt es noch die äh erworbene Immunantwort und das ist äh wo dann,
Antikörper.
Produziert werden, die speziell auf ein bestimmtes Virus zugeschnitten sind, aber ähm diese Infrastruktur muss halt normalerweise erstmal dann aufgebaut werden. Nun ist das Virus muss halt.
Erstmal ins Labor, also Körper hat halt so Labore, wo dann ähm sagen Antikörper erforscht werden und äh
züchtet werden und angeguckt wird, welche am besten funktionieren und die werden dann in größerer Menge produziert und äh ja, das ist dann eben die.
Erworbene Immunantwort, das, was letztlich auch äh oder was, was Impfstoffe versuchen hervorzurufen und
Erworbenen Immunantwort merkt sich aber, dass das Immunsystem dann die Baupläne und äh den den Virusprint, sodass wenn's jetzt das nächste Mal kommt, ist eben nicht sieben Tage dauert, sondern eben
auch die erworbene Immunantwort ganz ganz schnell reagieren kann und ganz spezifisch sofort äh halt dagegen vorgehen kann. So.
Ich sage die meisten oder viele andere Viren
haben halt Tricks auf Lager, um sowohl die angeborene als auch die erworbene Immunantwort zu schwächen oder durcheinander zu bringen, also sich zu verstecken.
Ähm versteckt sich aber nur vor
angeborenen Immunsystem wohl, in dem es irgendwie mit dem Interveron äh System äh trickst oder versucht, das äh aus dem Tritt zu bringen.
Sodass äh eben ja die.
Angeborene Immunantwort geschwächt ist. Es hat aber nichts, um dann anschließend die,
erworbene Immunantwort,
zu schwächen, sodass äh es dann dazu kommen kann so im Verlauf ähm du wirst infiziert
aber äh das angeborene Immunsystem äh springt halt erstmal nicht an oder nicht so richtig an
und das äh Virus kann sich halt damit erstmal relativ ungehindert ausbreiten und du hast halt auch keine Symptome, weil Symptome sind normalerweise nur die Reaktion des Immunsystems.
Und nicht äh jetzt Funktionsverlust äh der der Zelle durch durch die Infektion, sondern eben ja, dass das Immunsystem so.
Und.
Jetzt passiert dann also die ersten ja vier, fünf Tage passiert halt erstmal nicht viel außer, dass ich halt ähm das Virus äh erstmal ziemlich ungehemmt im Körper,
verbreitet und ganz viele Zellen ähm befällt und diese Zellen.
Werden dann aber so durch Mechanismen des Erworbenen Immunsystems
dann als krank markiert, da sind dann sozusagen draußen hängen dann an den Zellen schon so Signale hier, ich hab hier bin hier voll mit den und den Viren irgendwie alles nicht in Ordnung. So jetzt kommt,
dass ähm erworbene Immunsystem dann endlich an, hat halt jetzt äh ordentlich Armeen äh produziert,
und sie teilt jetzt plötzlich ganz, ganz viele Zellen, äh die krank sind und äh ja, veranstaltet jetzt erstmal ein Massaker. So und das nennt sich dann schwerer Verlauf. Ähm.
Umgekehrt, weil's halt aber so ist, dass natürlich jetzt das Virus nicht zu hundert Prozent, die.
Angeborene Immunantwort aushebelt, äh sondern nur zu einem gewissen Prozentsatz und das hängt eben davon auch ab, ja wie gut äh das ist, wie teilweise auch wie jung äh man ist oder wie gut das eigene.
System so funktioniert und wenn das,
dem Virus halt nicht gelingt, aus welchen Gründen auch immer diese angeborene,
Immunantwort wirklich zu unterdrücken, dann äh macht das angeborene Immunsystem einfach mit dem Virus ganz schnell den Garaus. Also es scheint äh in der Lage zu sein. Also wenn es denn,
sagen nicht außer Gefecht gesetzt wird dann,
bekämpft ist, dass Virus so gut, dass für das erworbene Immunsystem gar nicht mehr viel übrig bleibt, sodass sind dann quasi die
Symptomlosen oder Symptomarmen Verläufe und,
dafür, dass da was dran ist, spricht halt auch, dass man einerseits
durch auch in der Verrohung gaben, durch relativ frühe wohl Verläufe lindern kann
und umgekehrt, man festgestellt hat, dass äh Leute, die schwere Verläufe haben halt.
Auch defekte am Interveronsystem haben. Es gibt also ein paar genesische Defekte, wenn einem so,
bestimmte Stoffe aus der Interveron Familie fehlen, weil man die ja aufgrund eines genetischen Defekts hat man ein extrem hohes äh Risiko
für schwere Verläufe. Ja,
vielleicht noch äh so ein paar Dinge äh dazu
die mir geholfen haben mir das auch vorzustellen wie das abläuft also wenn so ein Saßkopf zwei Virus,
so eine Zelle befällt, dann füllt es die somit bis zu sechzig Prozent eigener RNA, das ist wohl ein ziemlich hoher Wert, also,
Vergleich mit anderen Viren und Zweigkalten Großteil des Produktionsapparats für die Zelle.
Für eigene Zwecke ab. Das ist halt natürlich dann auch nicht gut, wenn äh ich sage mal, wenn's Virus jetzt nur fünf Prozent nutzen würde, weil wir halt sagen, okay.
Zelle ist zwar jetzt zu fünf Prozent weniger produktiv
und so aber ja wer jetzt zolerabel aber wenn ihr halt jetzt sechzig Prozent der Zellaktivität durch durch das Virus gesteuert wird kann das einfach nicht gut sein für die Zelle gar nicht gut.
So
und im Zusammenhang mit Mutationen ist es jetzt natürlich so, dass Mutation an diesen Genen, mit denen das Virus, mit dem Immunsystem rumtrickst, natürlich gerade Krankheitsverläufe, Unsterblichkeit auch nochmal massiv beeinflussen.
So in jede Richtung im Grunde genommen, so und.
Nochmal, jetzt letzter Punkt, das war jetzt ein ziemlich langer Monologe. Ich hoffe, ähm das war jetzt alles nicht zu viel zu dicht, aber.
So das Virus montiert natürlich ständig im Körper, so aber die meisten Mutationen sind halt Sackgassen so, die,
Schwächen des Virus, aber ungefähr alle zwei Wochen im Durchschnitt findet man in freier Wildbahn ähm.
Eine Mutation, die das Virus nicht schlechter macht, also die zumindest halt jetzt äh,
zu einer Übertragung geführt hat und jetzt bei weiteren Übertragungen eben mit drin ist. Das sind also alle drei bis vier Übertragungen äh im Grunde genommen findet sich eine Mutation. So,
wenn wir also dann einfach weltweit auf die Zahlen,
gucken, dann kann man sagen, dass jede Woche so zwischen einer halben Million und eine Million neue Mutationen in die Welt kommen. Und jetzt nicht Motationen,
die das Virus schlechter machen, sondern dieses Virus entweder genauso gut oder besser machen so. Ja, wie gesagt, halbe Million äh neue.
Varianten und ich hatte mir dann mal angeguckt.
Auch noch äh weil ich mich erinnern konnte auch aus Drosten, Podcast und so das Thema Mutation.
War nie so im im Vordergrund. Du siehst immer, ja, ist ein relativ stabiles äh Virus,
und es ist auch ein hochoptimiertes Virus, das heißt äh dass das Virus besser werden kann, so ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, weil das ist schon so gut,
wie es denn nur geht, ja. Aber so äh dann im
haben wir halt gesehen mit der B eins eins sieben Variante, es geht halt doch nochmal deutlich besser und so.
Das wurde zwar wissenschaftlichen Konsens nie ausgeschlossen, dass es jetzt besser wird, aber er hat gesagt, es ist halt eher unwahrscheinlich so.
Und ja das meine Sicht
dahingehend verändert, dass bei so vielen Mutationen
dass da auch vermutlich noch eine Menge Potenzial ist, dass das Virus doch nochmal ansteckender äh oder tödlicher äh werden kann oder wie auch immer erfolgreicher,
so. Ja
Also das äh vielleicht noch zum zum Thema Mutation leider ja äh könnte sein, dass wir noch lange nicht
die Möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft haben oder das Virus noch nicht sein Potenzial ausgeschöpft hat, was so ähm Weiterentwicklung angeht.
Ein Grund mehr, dass.
Infektionszahlen insgesamt halt einfach gesenkt werden müssen. Selbst wenn's jetzt nicht zu einer totalen äh Auslöschung führt, was,
glaube ich sehr unwahrscheinlich ist zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt aber umso weiter diese.
Das Wachstum eingeschränkt werden kann oder zumindest oder oder die Verbreitung zurückgedrängt werden kann umso besser ist es, weil das dann eben bedeutet, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit auch solche kritischen Mutationen äh weiter gesenkt wird.
Und meine mit jeder mit jeder Welle sozusagen ähm ja.
Normalerweise für zehn bis verhundertfacht sich die Zahl der Fälle und der der Mutation äh im Moment und äh ja, es ist zwar ein Spiel mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten und wir können auch Glück haben,
aber ja wir wir fordern im Moment unser Glück eigentlich heraus und wenn wir Pech haben.
Nun haben wir eben im Sommer mit impfen nochmal von vorne anfangen.
Das ist das ist glaube ich das, was in der ganzen Debatte noch zu wenig.
Vordergrund ist und ich meine es zeichnet sich ja jetzt schon zumindest mit dieser Südafrika-Variante an, dass das auch nötig ist. Also das zumindest nochmal ein neuer
Wirkstoff gefunden werden muss, der eben diese spezifische Variante zurückdrängt. Also es ist noch nicht ganz klar, ne? Also haben wir ja auch schon drüber gesprochen. Äh es zeigt sich zwar eine schwächere ähm.
Reaktionen
Antikörper aber das ist ja nicht das Einzige in diesem Immunsystem, was greift, also es kann auch sehr wohl sein, dass die Impfstoffe helfen und dass zum Beispiel dieser Move von Südafrika, die in Astrid Sinnika-Impfstoff erstmal nicht zur Anwendung zu bringen. Vielleicht
gar nicht mal so eine gute Idee war, ne? Weil es sehr wohl hätte sein können, dass es besser wirkt, als sie das jetzt so in der Petrischale beobachtet haben,
Also jetzt sorgen wir schon wieder für schlechte Laune, ne? Ich meine, man kann natürlich äh wenn man jetzt mal hier auf unsere tollen Kurven schauen, wir haben jetzt hier viel über dieses Land und jenes Land natürlich vor allem viel über Deutschland äh gesprochen,
insgesamt, wenn man sich jetzt mal die Weltentwicklung anschaut, geht zumindest die Infektionsrate weltweit zurück. Ja, das ist die gute Nachricht.
Also man kann das bekämpfen, wir können das bekämpfen und auch ausrotten, wenn wir wollen, aber ähm dass äh Virus scheint auch.
Sagen so einen, so einen schwachen Punkt getroffen zu haben, ich sage mal in der Psyche.
Das ist nämlich ähm von der Tötlichkeit her nicht so krass ist äh jetzt wie bei Saas zwei, wo halt teilweise ich glaube dreißig Prozent oder so. Jeder Dritte gestorben ist,
der sich infiziert hat, wo dann man einfach ganz konsequent äh.
Draufgegangen ist, ne? Es hat sich so ein bisschen ja Stelzy
aber kann sich verstecken und macht halt jetzt auch nicht so viel Ärger, aber dann doch wieder deutlich mehr Ärger, als man eigentlich in großer Zahl tolerieren kann
und äh so ja ist das halt auch das perfekte Trollvirus sage ich mal mit den
halt die Menschheit getrollt wird
und äh ja äh ist halt für Streit sorgt, äh wenn's wenn's halt jetzt so Parameter wie, ja, Saß oder Ebula hätte, dann,
gibt's halt dieses ganze irgendwie gemeckere über Lokdown oder so gar nicht.
Aber um's nochmal kurz zu betonen, weil ich habe mir jetzt parallel auch nochmal so ein bisschen den Weltverlauf eben äh angeschaut. Wir hatten.
Piekt der gemessenen Infektionszahlen weltweit, also wird dich jetzt alles zusammengenommen, ne? Das ist lokal, dann äh nicht immer so entscheidend, aber wenn man jetzt mal so den Weltverlauf äh sich anschaut, hatten wir den Peak ungefähr Anfang
dieses Jahres,
Also wirklich so um den um den ersten äh die erste Januarwoche herum. Da sind die höchsten Zahlen gemeldet worden. Es ist überall nochmal hochgegangen in allen Kontinenten, ganz extrem in Nordamerika.
Nicht ganz so wild in Europa.
Noch ein bisschen besser in Südamerika und äh die einzigen, die sozusagen immer noch unterdurchschnittlich sind, Afrika und Asien. Seitdem hat sich ungefähr.
Die Zahl halbiert. So. Also das sind sozusagen jetzt schon die äh.
Relativ guten Nachrichten, weil ja ist halt einfach halbiert, aber ist halt einfach noch zu hoch.
Mein Halbieren ist was, was man eigentlich mit einem null siebener Lokdown äh in einer Woche machen kann. Ja.
Ja, aber das hat man ja schon. Schauen wir doch nochmal auf die Maßnahmen, die jetzt in Deutschland ergriffen werden
wenn auch schon zu wenig getan wird, äh was jetzt in der letzten Woche ein bisschen in der Diskussion aufkam, war die Frage der Schnelltests.
Und ich beobachte immer wieder, dass die Einschätzung darüber, was schnell Tests jetzt bringen und wo sie denn was bringen, erheblich auseinandergehen,
Also während man sich beim Impfen ja doch vergleichsweise einig sein kann ist so diese Anwendung des des Zielmittels, des des Schnelltests ist wirklich ein großes Durcheinander.
Vielleicht stehen wir jetzt.
Vor der Situation demnächst, dass eben diese Schnelltest für privat und an der Apotheke äh bald verfügbar sind. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt die Diskussion.
So richtig verfolgt bekommen, weil's dann doch irgendwie hin und her ging. Ich habe Zahlen gehört, wie dass wir so hundertsechzig.
Bedarf hätten von hundertsechzig Millionen Schnelltest pro Woche jetzt allein für Deutschland, um äh alles absichern zu können.
Teilweise wird es jetzt bei Schulen soll es verteilt werden für Veranstaltungen wäre es ja sowieso später dann ohnehin nochmal eine eine gute Methode.
Eindruck bekommen, wohin die Reise da jetzt gerade geht.
Also ich weiß nur, dass halt jetzt in Berlin der Senat halt für die Schulen.
Jetzt massiv auf Schnelltests setzt und äh jetzt beschlossen hat, dass alle Schüler, die wie ähm in Präsenz äh sind und eine Lehrer zweimal die Woche mit Schnelltests getestet haben.
So erstmal mein Eindruck ist, äh dass das Potenzial äh durch Schnelltests Übertragungen zu reduzieren groß ist,
Also.
Selbst wenn die Dinger nur neun von zehn ansteckenden erkennen sollten und ich glaube da tun sie halt deutlich mehr könnte man
in bestimmten Bereichen
dann wahrscheinlich ja äh auch mehr auch mindestens neun von zehn Übertragungen und vielleicht auch mehr verhindern, weil natürlich gerade die, äh die halt besonders viele Viren.
Ausscheiden auch mit.
Besonders großer Wahrscheinlichkeit äh gefunden werden und äh ja insofern.
Ist es mir ein absolutes Rätsel, warum wir da jetzt so lange gewartet haben.
Ich weiß schon noch im, im Juni oder Juli hat äh Drostnie schon angekündigt, dass die eigentlich jetzt schon fertig sind soweit und dass man da die Produktion hochfahren wird, aber äh ja.
Dann waren wahrscheinlich bei uns die Zahlen nicht so, dass irgendjemand eine Notwendigkeit gesehen hat,
Und als dann die Zahlen so hoch waren, dass die Notwendigkeit da gewesen wäre, waren wahrscheinlich nicht genug Tests da, weil das Interesse vorher nicht hoch genug war, dass die Produktion nicht genug hochgefahren wurde, irgendwie sowas kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ja, das Ganze wird dann eben natürlich auch noch begleitet von ähm solchen Diskussionen um na ja, wenn jetzt äh da zu viele äh falsch,
Also Leute sich sozusagen bei negativen Tests zu sehr in Sicherheit wiegen, ja? Weil sie nur auch diesen Schnelltest vertrauen und wenn der dann halt negativ ist, das dann äh entsprechend.
Sicher durch die Welt schreiten und sagen, na ja ich hab's ja nicht so, ich kann's ja nicht verbreiten, also kann ich jetzt hier rumlaufen, wie ich will.
Das ist äh so ein Problem. Also es scheint mir wirklich so
mentaler Knoten zu sein, der dieser ganzen Diskussion drin ist und es wird sich auch wahrscheinlich kaum auflösen können, bevor man eben nicht in irgendeiner Form eine hohe Verfügbarkeit und eine leichte Anwendbarkeit äh erreicht hat. Also im Prinzip
dieses kostenlose Verteilen an Schulen und das konsequente Anwenden von Schnelltest an Schulen, denke ich mal, ist absolut erforderlich, wenn man denn,
Schulen öffnet,
ja, dann wäre es einfach wichtig, was das dazu kommt, ist, dass äh jetzt zumindest in der Debatte steht, also Niedersachsen hat da glaube ich einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht, zu sagen.
Wir sollten jetzt auch die Lehrer und Erzieherinnen in die höhere Impfkategorie einsortieren, dass man also den Beschluss dahingehend ändert, dass man sagt, na ja, wenn schon Schulen dann zumindest die Lehrer noch mit äh absichern, was.
Sicherlich keine schlechte Idee ist, ne? Ich meine, bleiben natürlich immer noch die Schüler. Es ist.
Äh es ist ja nicht, das ist ja nicht so, dass das Problem äh da nur von den Lehrern ausgeht, ist halt nur so, dass die dann eben äh da in der Regel eben deutlich älter sind, also,
weil sie älter sind, äh, natürlich einen größeren Risiko ausgesetzt sind und es vollkommen okay wäre, dieses Risiko für für diese Gruppe zu senken.
Ja eigentlich würde ich sogar fast provokativ sagen wenn jetzt Schulunterricht wirklich wichtig wäre und Priorität vor allem an würde man halt Lehrer und Schüler zuerst impfen.
Ja gut, aber die Schüler kannst du derzeit nicht impfen. Weil wir einfach da diese ganze äh die ganze Sicherheit einfach noch nicht haben für für.
Jugendliche unter sechzehn Jahren. Es hat einfach nicht nicht machbar.
Ja. Ich glaube gut in anderen Ländern.
Ähm läuft es aber äh schon. Ich glaube, Israel bis zwölf.
Glaube ich, runter, wird wird geimpft und ja, also es wird davon ausgegangen, dass ab Sommer äh irgendwie wahrscheinlich früher schon auch Impfungen von Kindern möglich sein werden.
Sicher.
Also Studien laufen, aber sind halt noch nicht abgeschlossen so und deswegen äh ist es glaube ich auch sinnvoll an der Stelle. Ja, nochmal äh.
Andere Maßnahmen zu finden, bis das eben auch durchgeführt werden kann.
Man ja und natürlich halte ich, ich sage mal so, wie wir äh jetzt impfende sicherlich die äh ja, ethisch äh.
Und epidemiologisch sinnvolle Variante, also ist jetzt nicht also reine Pedium
Biologisch könnte man sich wahrscheinlich noch äh was anderes vorstellen, aber gerade um halt äh so die Auswirkungen, also,
schwere Verläufe zu vermeiden. Das ist glaube ich der der Hauptpunkt.
So hat man halt, glaube ich, die Modelle optimiert. Dahingehend.
Und das ist ist auch richtig, also nicht, dass jemand denkt, ich würde jetzt fordern, dass jetzt äh Schüler zuerst geimpft werden, aber Lehrern macht es sicherlich auf jeden Fall auch äh auf jeden Fall Sinn.
Nicht nur mit einer Klasse in Verbindung sind, sondern ja teilweise, weiß ich nicht, zwei, drei, vier Klassen.
Am Tag möglicherweise unterrichten und äh ja hätte ich jetzt auch keine Probleme mit.
Neidtechnisch meine ich.
So, dann lass uns doch mal schauen, wie es denn eigentlich mit den Impfungen in Deutschland so vorangeht und was da so ein bisschen die Rahmenparameter sind
Äh ich denke auf der positiven Seite kann man vermerken, dass äh die Impfung noch laufen.
Äh
die Zahl der täglich verabreichten Impfung ist nicht nennenswert
gestiegen, also das bewegt sich alles immer noch äh auf der selben Tradikorie. Wir haben jetzt äh eins äh drei Komma
Eins sieben neun Millionen Erstmalig geimpfte und knapp eins Komma sieben Millionen.
Die schon ihre zweite Impfung erhalten haben.
Wenn man halt schaut, wie das so mit den Lieferungen äh angeht, was ja relevant wäre jetzt für eine Steigerung. Da tut sich jetzt halt was.
Denn äh diese Astrazenika äh Impfstoffe kommen jetzt mit,
ins Spiel und nehmen auch in zunehmenden Maße einen größeren Anteil an, während also moderner, noch sehr rein, sehr gering reintröpfelt,
sehe ich das so, dass jetzt in den letzten Tagen sehr viel mehr.
Impfstoff von Astra Zenika dazu gekommen ist, als wir glaube ich ja, fast insgesamt von moderner so hatten
sprich es entsteht jetzt ein leichter Vorsprung, also wir haben jetzt tatsächlich mal einen gewissen Abstand zwischen den tatsächlich verabreichten Impfdosen und das, was theoretisch eben verimpfbar,
wäre.
Es gibt da ja eine Debatte um diesen Astracenica Impfstoff, der scheint jetzt einen extrem schlechten Ruf gehabt zu haben.
Weil dieser Faktor, der Effektivität so in den Vordergrund geraten ist, ja, also.
Erinnern wir uns diese Phase drei Studien bewerten ja letzten Endes den Erfolg danach, wie sehr eben solche schweren Verläufe.
Äh eingeschränkt werden konnten. Also wie viel treten sozusagen überhaupt noch auf? Und da hatten ja die MRNA-Impfstoffe.
Diese besonders beeindruckende Zahlen von vierundneunzig, fünfundneunzig Prozent und Bastra Cineca bei dem Impfstoff war es halt geringere Zahlen.
Und diese sechzig Prozent, die dann äh im Spiel sind,
wurden dann glaube ich von vielen Leuten so missverstanden ja dass das sozusagen nicht hilft, dass man so nur eine sechzig Prozent Chance hat so und wenn man wie in diesen sechzig Prozent nicht isst, dann stirbt man,
Das ist aber nicht der Fall, ne, sondern das, das ist nicht das, was das aussagt.
Denn auch bei Astra Cenica äh ist also die Wirkung schon so, dass Leute dann einfach nicht versterben und dass also der Schutz gegen schwere Verläufe sehr wohl da ist
nur, dass man eben höhere Zahlen von ja Erkrankungen gesehen hat, aber die dann eben nicht äh zum Tode geführt haben
Und in dieser ganzen Debatte scheint es jetzt, dass so die Leute soweit verunsichert zu haben, dass viele dann ihren Impftermin überhaupt nicht angetreten sind, wo
dem sie erfahren haben, dass da eben jetzt äh dieser Astracenica in Stoff verimpft werden soll. Das natürlich beunruhigend. Muss man jetzt mal
ich glaube auch die Tatsache, dass eben noch nicht genug Studienmaterial für ältere Leute da war, die Leute auch so ein bisschen abgeschreckt, dass er erstmal nur bis
fünfundfünfzig oder bis fünfundsechzig, je nach Land äh freigegeben wurde, hat auch alles nicht unbedingt dazu beigetragen,
hier den Leuten klarzumachen, dass das sehr wohl ein Impfstoff ist, der hilft.
Man kann es.
Vielleicht auf den Punkt bringen, dass auch der Astra SEKA-Impfstoff praktisch zu hundert Prozent äh davor bewahrt. Ähm daran zu sterben an äh Kobit.
Genau. Also ich habe es schön drin äh Twit gesehen von dem Doktor Lübers, der meinte,
sich mit Astrazinika-Impf zu letzten Schütz vor schweren Infektionen und reduziert die Weitergabe des Virus und wahrscheinlich auch das Auftreten von Long Coved. Sich nicht impfen zu lassen, schützt vor nichts, reduziert nichts und verhindert nichts,
Schwierige Entscheidung.
Ja also das äh ist definitiv so ein Faktor und äh ich denke man kann einfach festhalten, wenn ihr die Gelegenheit habt, euch mit Astrazenica-Impfstoff impfen zu lassen,
macht es, es ist gut für euch, es hilft und äh mit
sehr, sehr, sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit, äh kann es eben äh schwere Verläufe und Todes äh Fälle eben verhindern und genau das ist das, was dieser Impfstoff tun soll.
In den Kommentaren tatsächlich gab's einen schönen Link, den ich so noch nicht gesehen hatte, wo mal wirklich aufgestellt wurde, mit welchen Lieferungen wir denn jetzt sozusagen zu rechnen haben.
Und ich äh das ist jetzt hier auch einzeln aufgeführt, den Link findet ihr in den Shownotes,
Das ist jetzt sozusagen alles das, was bestellt wurde und was eben auch an Lieferzusagen getan wurde
äh zusammengerechnet. Also es ist einzeln aufgeführt nach den einzelnen Impfstoffen und da ist jetzt äh sowohl der Johnson and Johnson Impfstoff mit drin, der ja die Zulassung noch nicht hat, als auch der Cuwak
der noch nicht ähm ja der auch glaube ich seine Phase drei noch nicht äh abgeschlossen hat.
Und natürlich auch noch nicht für die Zulassung beantragt wurde,
die machen dann aber auch einen relativ geringen Teil aus. Wenn man jetzt mal da drauf schaut, dann sieht man im letzten Quartal, also im letzten Quartal zwanzig zwanzig
Also die Gesamtliefermenge lag halt bei eins Komma drei,
Millionen Impfdosen, das war dann halt ausschließlich der Biontech Fiser im Stoff. Dann jetzt im ersten Quartal, also bis Ende März
werden es dann achtzehn Komma drei Millionen gewesen sein. Es bezieht sich jetzt ausschließlich auf Deutschland übrigens, ne? Im zweiten Quartal.
Werden es dann aber siebenundsiebzig Millionen sein. Also die Zahl,
der verfügbaren Impfdosen wird sich dann entsprechend verdreifachen.
Und im dritten Quartal ist mit hundertsechsundzwanzig Millionen zu rechnen. Also mal.
Nochmal so das sechs siebenfache von dem, was wir in diesem Quartal sehen. Und dann im vierten Quartal nochmal hundert Millionen.
Also davon auszugehen, dass wir eine gewisse Axeleration im ganzen Impfgeschehen in Deutschland sehen werden, signifikant an Natur,
dass äh ja hoffentlich dann eben auch alle rechtzeitig noch einen Termin kriegen und auch eine Impfung bekommen können.
Also wenn die Zahlen so eintreten, kann man davon ausgehen, dass im zweiten Quartal.
Also bis Ende Juni wahrscheinlich alle Prioritätsgruppen durch sein werden.
Und wir äh wahrscheinlich im Quartal drei dann.
Ähm eine allgemeine Freigabe kriegen und das dann sich äh im Prinzip jener impfen lassen kann. Also im Quartal drei. Irgendwann sollte dann genug im Stoff für alle äh.
Zur Verfügung stehen. Ja.
Korreliert eigentlich dann auch mit den Aussagen. Ich glaube von Sparen so ab September meinte er gibt's genug Impfstoff für alle und den Zahlen nach, zumindest die ich hier sehe klingt das plausibel.
Bei der Süddeutschen Zeitung bin ich dann noch auf den Impfpott gestoßen, da kann man äh mal drauf äh klicken und gibt so seine Rahmenparameter ein und dann äh zum Schluss benennt man noch das Bundesland,
aus dem man kommt und dann äh wird eine Einschätzung gemacht, äh wann man denn wohl so dran sein könnte, wenn die Kampagne im geplanten Tempo läuft. In meinem Fall wäre das ungefähr ab Juli zwanzig einundzwanzig.
Impfungen in der bisherigen Geschwindigkeit weiter könnte es aber auch bis Mai dreiundzwanzig dauern. Wovon nicht auszugehen ist, wie ich ja gerade ausgeführt habe.
Den Link habe ich jetzt natürlich auch in den Shownotes.
Dann sollen wir nochmal einen Blick nach Israel wagen. Da äh erwarten wir ja nun schon seit längerem neue Erkenntnisse darüber, wie äh sich zumindest das Pfeiser
der Pfeiserimpfstoff auf diese ganze Gesamtsituation so auswirkt.
Da gibt's tatsächlich eine ganze Reihe von,
Studien, also sowohl die hier schon mal erwähnte Klarlied Health Service Research Institut hat da was
gemacht und noch ein äh sogenannter Makaby Health Care Service und ja es
die ganzen Zahlen im Einzelnen runterbieten, aber die haben halt Studien gemacht mit sehr vielen Leuten, also in der ersten Studie wurden eins Komma zwei Millionen Leute ausgewertet, also äh,
quasi immer so zwei Gruppen, ne, Geimpfte, nicht geimpfte, also ungefähr sechshunderttausend pro Gruppe.
In unterschiedlichen Altersgruppen eingeteilt, äh über sechzig unter sechzig und bei der zweiten waren's nicht,
ganz so viel, aber so in der gleichen Größenordnung und es zeigen sich eigentlich konsistent dieselben Ergebnisse, nämlich so eine Wirksamkeit von vierundneunzig bis fünfundneunzig Prozent, also,
ziemlich genau das, was auch in der Phase drei Studie von dem Pfeiser im Stoff ähm vorhergesagt wurde oder ermittelt wurde. Ähm.
Kein einziger Todesfall, bei dem die geimpft wurden,
und ja das sind alles extrem gute Zahlen generell sechzig Prozent weniger Erkrankungen bei sechzig plus.
Also der Impfstoff hilft quasi äh auf allen Ebenen.
Und dann gibt's auch noch eine dritte Studie vom Weizmann Institut die ähm.
Auch untersucht haben, wie denn das so generell sich auf die Neuinfektion auswirkt und das ist ja immer die große Frage, die im Raum stand, so, ne. Okay.
Ja vielleicht noch äh sagen insgesamt aber wohl äh aus dem.
Clarit äh Artikel äh geht halt hervor, dass ähm sagen symptomatische Infektionen insgesamt um vierundneunzig Prozent reduziert werden.
Das hatte ich ja vorhin gesagt, jetzt die diese Effektivität liegt bei vierundneunzig oder fünfundneunzig Prozent.
Was sozusagen, was das bedeutet äh äh immer, weil weil es ist ja immer so, so äh in wie vielen Fällen verhindert es denn jetzt eigentlich die Infektion äh aber das äh geht nicht um die Infektion, sondern um symptomatische Infektion.
Richtig, genau, ne? Weil nicht alle ja nochmal getestet werden, ob sie sich infiziert haben.
Sondern weil er nur geschaut wird, wer wird krank? Und das merkt man natürlich nur bei denen, die auch entsprechende Krankheitssymptome zeigen.
Und das ist ja auch das, was ich vorhin mit Astra-Senica meint. Das ist das, was da halt untersucht wurde. So, aha, nur.
Eine symptomatische Erkrankung haben.
Davon einen wirklich schweren Verlauf zu bekommen oder eben zu sterben. Das sind nochmal so zwei verschiedene Sachen, ne? Und ja auch der Astra Sinnika-Impfstoff hilft da eben extrem.
Also Todesfälle verhindert schwere Erkrankungen, nur werden halt mehr Leute unter Umständen,
Zumindest nach den derzeitigen Zahlen lagen trotzdem noch irgendwie bei einer Infektion krank, aber sie leiden halt unter dieser Krankheit nicht, weil der Körper in der Lage ist beim Auftreten dieser Krankheit.
Schneller das Immunsystem hochzufahren, effizienter zu bekämpfen und damit dann eben die unerwünschten Nebenwirkungen sozusagen im Schach zu halten.
Man kann dann sagen wir vielleicht noch das Modell von wohin sie sagen mit der Reaktion des sagen,
angeborenen und erworbenen Immunsystems nach einer Impfung ist es so, dass einfach das äh Erworbene,
System sich wesentlich schneller an die Arbeit machen kann, erstmal nicht diese siebentägige Forschung
veranstalten muss, welche Art von Antikörpern es denn jetzt produzieren muss, sondern die, da liegen die Baupläne dann schon vor und das führt dann eben auch dazu, dass äh erstmal nicht so viele,
Zellen befallen, äh, äh, werden, bevor das Immunsystem da schon loslegen kann und.
Natürlich je mehr Zellen befallen sind, umso schwerer potentiell der Verlauf, äh wenn das Immunsystem dann loslegt.
Insofern ja macht es halt alles Sinn, insbesondere was schwere Falläufe an angeht, dass es da extrem wirksam ist.
Genau, so jetzt nochmal zu dieser dritten äh Studie bei diesem Weizmann-Institut. Die haben sich ja dann halt auch nochmal angeschaut, wie denn das eigentlich jetzt ähm also sie haben ähnliche Zahlen auch nochmal, was so die die Erkrankung betrifft, ähm generiert
und die von denen stammt auch glaube ich die Aussage, dass eben die Neuinfektion äh
auch entsprechend zurückging. Also das ist dann sozusagen auch hier ist eine Analyse mit
wie viel Infektionen gibt's da? Nicht, weil jetzt alle nochmal getestet wurden, sondern man hat sich das dann eben über die gesamte Gruppe äh angeschaut und eben verglichen, Städte
früher geimpft wurden, versus, welche, wo das später angefangen hat, et cetera. Diese ganze Methode, das hatten wir letztes Mal, glaube ich, auch schon angesprochen.
Und dann lässt sich also jetzt ablesen bei sechzig plus ging die Infektionsrate um.
Fünfzig Prozent zurück.
Bei jüngeren Minussicht, also kleiner jünger als sechzig Jahre um zwanzig Prozent, weil.
Eben noch nicht so viele ähm geimpft wurden, ne? Weil sechzig plus hat jetzt eine Impfrate in Israel von neunzig Prozent. Äh erste Impfung, achtzig Prozent, zweite Impfung und bei unter sechzig ist es halt ungefähr,
die Hälfte ja weniger noch als die Hälfte, also vierzig Prozent haben die erste Impfung bekommen, zwanzig Prozent, haben die zweite Impfung bekommen und es lässt sich halt einfach,
durch die Analyse der statistischen Daten eben schon dieser Schluss ziehen. Also da, wo eine hohe Impfquote vorliegt
Achtzig, neunzig Prozent. Da gehen dann auch die Infektionen messbar zurück. Um.
Fünfzig Prozent und bei dem wo man eben noch nicht ganz so weit ist um zwanzig Prozent. Aber bei allen geht sie zurück,
und das sind gute Nachrichten und das sind die Nachrichten, die wir uns eigentlich erhofft haben.
Auf die Frage warum denn äh die Neuinfektion zurückgehen.
Äh gibt's auch noch Untersuchungen und,
Das lese ich im Wesentlichen so, dass man einfach feststellt, dass bei den Leuten, die geimpft sind, die Viruslast deutlich sinkt.
Also man hat halt Leute, die sich zwar infiziert haben, noch aber schon geimpft waren.
Im Verglichen, also Proben genommen und diese Viruslast bestimmt und das dann eben im Vergleich zu Leuten, die nicht geimpft waren und sich infiziert haben. Und diese Viruslast kann ja im Rahmen dieser PCR-Tests durchgeführt werden und zwar,
nimmt man ja 'ne Probe.
Tut ihr dann dieses PCR, in diesen PCR-Test rein, in dieser PCR-Test funktioniert ja dadurch, dass quasi dieses diese kleine Menge an Genmaterial äh.
In verschiedenen Durchläufen immer wieder verdoppelt und verdoppelt und verdoppelt und verdoppelt wird
Dieser Prozess wird immer wiederholt, das ist so dieses dieser mechanische äh Ablauf, der durch diese PCR-Maschinen im hochautomatisiert ist,
und dieser CT-Wert, der dabei rauskommt, das ist im Prinzip die Anzahl der Duplikationen, die man hat durchführen müssen
bis eben der Beleg war, aha das Virus ist auch wirklich da gewesen. Hast du eine hohe Viruslast, musst du nicht so viel verdoppeln, weil du siehst es dann schon sehr viel früher und umso geringer eben diese Viruslast ist äh umso.
Höher ist dann am Ende dieser CT-Wert und bei den geimpften war es wohl so, dass der so ungefähr um zwei
höher lag, also du bräuchtest quasi zwei Verdopplungen, sprich Faktor vier äh hat sich äh die Viruslast unterschieden. Und das,
ist eine auch eine sehr gute Nachricht, denn das ist das, was man sich so ein bisschen erhofft hat, dass eben eine Impfung eben nicht nur, was sie ja tut.
Schwere Verläufe und Todesfälle verhindert, sondern eben auch einfach schon so früh das Virus bekämpft im Körper.
Dass es eben auch gar nicht mehr die Möglichkeit hat, sich überhaupt im Rachenbereich so weit auszubreiten und dann eben potenziell auch schon wieder weiter verbreitet zu werden.
Und es sind auch alles sehr gute.
Äh Informationen. Also ich finde das äh hochgradig positiv, was dabei herauskommt und man kann nur hoffen, dass es so weitergeht, aber das ist zumindest äh soweit alles wie bestellt.
Ja, das ist doch sehr erfreulich.
Ja
Bei den Lymphstoffen selber äh tut sich was. Ich äh äh wollte eigentlich heute schon nochmal ein bisschen genauer auf dieses Johnson und Johnson äh wachsin,
eingehen, das muss sie nochmal so auf nächste Woche verschieben, habe ich noch nicht so die Zeit gefunden, aber äh ich habe ein paar Links für euch. Es gibt bei den New York Times äh schöne interaktive Erläuterungen
diese einzelnen Impfstoffe alle funktionieren. Also da gibt es quasi so für jeden.
So 'ne eigene Erklärbarseite, die sehr verständlich gemacht ist, also erstmal generell wie die Impfstoffe funktionieren und dann eben spezifisch auch eben für ähm Fiser, moderner.
Und eben auch die, die für uns noch relativ neu sind, also der Johnson and Johnson im Stoff, der.
Insofern ja auch besonders ist das, dass es der erste Impfstoff ist, bei dem nur eine Dosis vergeben werden soll.
Aber auch hier dieser Gamalia, also Sputwig fünf, der russische Impfstoff und Novawax, was äh auch äh demnächst noch auf den Markt kommt, ist dort alles schon von der Funktion her beschrieben worden.
How nein Cover Nine Teen, Backseens Work heißt die Seite, also neun verschiedene Impfstoffe sind da entsprechend präsentiert. Ja.
Ja ich bin ja sehr gespannt auch auf die Studienergebnisse, wenn man von den anderen Impfstoffen, aber da haben wir ja noch nichts, äh, bisher ist noch nichts aufgetaucht.
Gibt halt nur diese Zwischenergebnisse von äh dem Gamalea, dem dem Sputnik äh das äh hatten wir hier auch schon berichtet am,
aber richtige Ergebnisse, das werden wir dann halt sehen, wenn die beantragt sind. Bei Johnson und Johnson soll's wohl jetzt demnächst zu dieser Beantragung kommen. Das wird wohl alles in der nächsten Zeit passieren und dann werden natürlich auch diese Ergebnisse,
entsprechend präsentiert werden.
Dann gibt's noch gute Nachrichten von Biontech, Pfeiser und zwar haben die jetzt äh nochmal überprüft,
bei welchen Temperaturen denn eigentlich ja.
Impfstoff jetzt noch so überlebt, die waren ja da sehr konservativ und haben am Anfang gesagt, na ja, so minus siebzig Grad müsste es schon sein, nur dann können wir uns sicher sein, dass dass der auch lange hält,
Und jetzt haben sie da sich nochmal drauf gestürzt auf das Thema und haben halt ihren Impfstoff auch bei niedrigeren Temperaturen.
Richtig. Bei höheren Temperaturen äh gelagert und äh ich weiß nicht ganz genau, auf welche Art und Weise sie dann überprüft haben, dass diese noch
genauso stabil sind äh et cetera, aber haben sie auf jeden Fall äh Endergebnis ist
Man muss nicht mehr bis minus sechzig, siebzig Grad gehen, sondern es reicht jetzt der ähm,
Der Temperaturbereich von minus fünfzehn Grad Celsius bis minus fünfundzwanzig Grad Celsius.
Dass es eine extrem gute Nachricht, weil das bedeutet äh, dass man eben nicht so ähm spezielle Kühlschränke braucht.
Dass man die Dinger im normalen Tiefkühlschrank lagern kann.
Genau oder zumindest bei den Kühlschränken, die auch so bei normalen Impfzentren üblicherweise ohnehin vorhanden sind.
Daraus ergibt sich auch dieser Range, ne? Also dieser Range ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie gesagt haben äh,
die haben wir alle ausprobiert, sondern es ist eben so eine gewisse Kategorie von Kühlschränken, die halt in diesem Bereich sind und wenn eben dieser Bereich sichergestellt werden kann, dann äh passt das schon.
Mit dem im Stoff. Und damit schließt halt das Pfeiser äh der Pfeiserimpfstoff ein bisschen auf zu moderner, die ja von vornherein schon mit niedrigen Temperaturen rangegangen sind und das sind natürlich insbesondere gute Nachrichten für Länder,
die jetzt sicherlich Schwierigkeiten gehabt hätten, eine größere Infrastruktur aufzubauen und Kühlketten, die halt wirklich auch im Transport dann minus siebzig Grad sicherstellen kann.
Ja, nee, vor allen Dingen.
Finde ich das deswegen ganz erfreulich, weil man dann damit auch rechnen kann, äh dass der Impfstoff auch bei äh niedergelassenen Ärzten dann verfügbar sein wird.
Genau, das kann es bedeuten und was,
auch noch bekannt gegeben wurde ist, dass sie wohl in zunehmenden Maße davon ausgehen, dass ihr Impfstoff auch einfach schon sehr gut wirkt nach der ersten Dosis. Die ganzen.
Tests sind ja mit zwei Dosierungen durchgeführt worden und.
Es zeigt sich wohl auch, dass die zweite Dosis durchaus sinnvoll sein kann, ja? Aber das schon die Effektivität nach einer Dosis schon bei fünfundachtzig Prozent liegt.
Und das ist natürlich äh auch eine gute Nachricht. Bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, inwiefern das dann auch gleich in äh die.
Ähm Impfstrategien, Einfluss haben wird auf jeden Fall
kann man eben einer Impfstoffknappheit unter Umständen auch einfach erstmal ganz praktisch. Dadurch begegnen erstmal sagt naja okay, wir geben jetzt erstmal nur eine Dosis raus und äh schon dadurch würde sich das extrem ver,
bessern und man kann bei höherer Verfügbarkeit dann halt auch später noch nachimpfen.
Ja, ich hörte jetzt noch äh einen langen Pizza keine Studie dazu, aber äh insofern verschiedenen Seiten das wohl Impfreaktionen äh bei Astra Sinnika ähm.
Ihr bei der Erstimpfung auftreten, während sie bei äh Bier und ich bei der zweiten Impfung auftreten.
Dass es mir so zu Ohren gekommen, aber.
Ja na ja halt also wie heftig der Körper drauf drauf reagiert.
Bei moderner soll's andersrum sein, bei Moderna soll's bei der ersten Impfung so sein oder was.
Nee bei Astra Sinnika, äh, bei der ersten und bei Pfeiser bei Bayern Tech Pfeiser bei der zweiten, bei moderner weiß ich nicht, würde aber wahrscheinlich dann,
wenn das so stimmt auch er. Ähm wie bei Bayern Tech Pfeifer.
Das mag sein, habe ich jetzt nicht verfolgt, ist halt letztlich auch egal, ne? Man, wie gesagt, äh hier muss man einfach immer verstehen, Nebenwirkungen sind auch in gewisser Hinsicht erwünscht.
Ja, es ist insofern äh halt äh psychologisch noch einen Unterschied äh sozusagen, wenn bei deiner Erstimpfung einfach nichts passiert äh so.
Dann äh ja ähm.
Aber in äh wenn bei Astra Seneka hatte sich ja irgendwo dann die Hälfte der Leute dann krankschreiben lassen für zwei Tage wegen der Impfreaktion irgendwo angeblich im in eine.
So im Krankenhaus in Deutschland ja.
Genau. Und äh sagen ist.
Sagen, macht jetzt kein, nicht, nicht wirklich einen Unterschied, nur eben sagen psychologisch vielleicht, wenn bei dem einen Impfstoff äh,
das Gro der Leute erstmal bei der Erstimpfung das Gefühl, da passiert jetzt nicht viel, während die anderen denken, oh, der ist aber heftiger, so. Egal
Ding am Rande.
Ja, ich meine das mit der Nebenwirkung ist so ein bisschen aufgebläht worden, dass es dann auch so ein Schubler Kreisen äh gerne wieder dankend aufgenommen worden, so nach dem Motto Nebenwirkungen wären ja irgendwie gefährlich. Das normal, ja?
Ich weiß, ich weiß ja noch nicht mal, ob das Nebenwirkungen.
Ja, ja, das waren einfach die Auswirkungen von der Impfung als solcher. Und die haben halt das komplette Krankenhauspersonal geimpft und dann war halt der Anteil derer, die halt wirklich gesagt haben, so oh mir ist aber jetzt erstmal hier, jetzt mache ich erstmal ein, zwei Tage äh äh Pause
war dann relativ hoch und dann hatten sie irgendwie dreißig Prozent Personalausfall, was dann halt sozusagen das Krankenhaus so ein bisschen in die Bredouille gebracht hat.
Ich meine, grundsätzlich ist die Empfehlung altern nach jeder Impfung eigentlich so zwei, drei Tage lang erstmal.
Ja kein Stress und keine körperliche Anstrengung und so, also insofern wär's einfach sinnvoll ohnehin wenn die Leute dann zu Hause bleiben.
Genau, das heißt für so ein Krankenhaus bedeutet das einfach, ihr Impfen natürlich nicht alle am selben Tag.
Sondern ihr streckt das halt und sagt irgendwie, was weiß ich, zehn Prozent diese Woche und so weiter und dann äh oder zwanzig, keine Ahnung, muss man sich halt muss man sich halt einen Kopf drum machen, ein Krankenhaus sollte von sowas schon mal gehört haben.
Mhm. Eigentlich ja.
Eigentlich ja, ne?
Würde man denken, aber ähm.
Ja, dann das passt dann vielleicht an dieser Stelle noch, das war nämlich auch etwas, was mir vor drei Tagen aufgefallen ist, was wir vielleicht äh auch noch hier äh mal reinpacken sollten oder weiß ich.
Was ich gerne noch loswerden würde und zwar entbrannte dann ja die Debatte äh so.
Welcher Institanz können eigentlich die Gesundheitsämter ähm.
Einen sinnvollen Beitrag äh mit Tracking und Tracing.
Ähm leisten und wo verlieren sie die Kontrolle? Da gab's ja bisher sozusagen immer diese Kontrollverlusttheorie bei bei fünfzig, dass sie dann einfach,
überfordert sind. Ähm und das dann aber dadrunter in dem
Moment wo sie denn dann tracken und plötzlich der Beitrag zur Infektionsreduktion größer wird bei einer niedrigen Institanz und.
Ähm ich bin dem halt mal nachgegangen und ich konnte halt keinen solchen Schwellwert finden. So.
Bei dem es jetzt plötzlich sehr viel besser wird.
Wie die Gesundheitsämter trappen und tracen können und so,
sondern es ist wahrscheinlich eher ein ja vielleicht nicht ganz linearer Zusammenhang, aber es ist halt eine Kurve. Das heißt, je weniger,
Infektion umso besser
können die Gesundheitsämter tracken und je mehr umso mehr fallen durchs Rost, aber es ist eben nicht so klar bei ganz hohen Institzen irgendwann, aber äh
je nach Gesundheitsamt auch kriegt man.
Unterschiedliche Informationen zu dieser wie wie weit sie denn können. Das hatten wir ja auch die Information aus Köln. Äh dass dort.
Das Gesundheitsamt sagt, wir können noch bis Institanz dreihundert tracken so und äh
dem, das hatte ich dann zwar erstmal angezweifelt, aber äh inzwischen halte ich das durchaus möglich und zwar deswegen, weil einfach die Art und Weise.
Wie bei uns.
Getrackt wird, wie bei uns isoliert wird, ähm! Wie bei uns Kontakte eingestuft werden lässt.
Nicht nur zu wünschen übrig, sondern ich würde es als mittlerweile als mittelgroße Katastrophe bezeichnen und
Wer sich wundert, warum die Gesundheitsämter das nicht in Griff kriegen bei keiner Institut sich dann nur anzuschauen zu sagen wie die Kontakte,
klassifiziert werden sollen.
Das ist schon nicht ganz ohne oder unproblematisch und wenn man dann aber noch guckt, was die Gesundheitsämter in der Praxis machen, stellt man fest, dass sie,
nicht einmal die Empfehlung des RKI befolgen oder kennen, sondern da wird halt sagen bei der Kontaktklassifizierung werden
wird verharmlosend,
äh Qualifiz äh äh Klassifiziert. Da gibt's ja sozusagen Kontakte der Kategorie eins und zwei und ähm ganz viele,
eigentlich Kategorie eins Kontakte oder Kontakte, die eigentlich Kategorie eins sein müssten, werden aus mir unklaren Gründen äh definitiv unter Verstoß gegen die Empfehlungen des RKI als,
Kontakte der Klasse zwei qualifiziert wo dann kein Test erforderlich ist beziehungsweise kein Testangeordnet wird und.
Ähm dann ist es so, sekundär Kontakte werden auf Empfehlung des RKI gar nicht getrast.
Ja
So, das heißt, wenn du dir jetzt diesen ganzen Prozess anguckst, auch wie lange er dauert, nämlich diese zehn Tage von äh so Meldung bis äh Zählung, so wie lange Tests dauern.
Dann.
Ist das Tracen von Sekundärkontakten unbedingt notwendig, weil sonst bei einer seriellen, bei einem seriellen Intervall von vier Tagen,
kannst du nicht irgendwie ja die Sekundärkontakte einfach komplett ignorieren und also.
Nachdem ich das alles gesehen habe, wie eigentlich aus meiner Sicht völlig,
in Adäquat das ganze äh Tracking und Tracing funktioniert, das schon bei den Empfehlungen.
Selbst die Empfehlungen werden von den Gesundheitsämtern einfach nicht beachtet, ich weiß nicht, ob sie es nicht kennen oder,
wie auch immer so und deswegen ja äh ist halt auch äh deswegen.
Sind wir auch überhaupt in den Lokdown, in den äh äh reingekommen, beziehungsweise in die zweite Welle, weil einfach diese dieses.
Sicherheitsebene oder diese diese Art der Reduktion von R durch die Gesundheitsämter.
Ist Marginal. Es ist halt so gebaut, damit äh nicht zu viel Unbequemlichkeiten entstehen. Plus unsere Sachen hatten wir ja schon, wie dann Arbeitsgarantäne und so ist es einfach, ja.
Wir meinen das nicht wirklich ernst.
So, dann wollte ich nochmal auf zwei.
Nachrichtenmeldungen kommen, die so ein bisschen die Medien ähm umspült haben, zwei unterschiedliche Sachen. Das Erste ist mal wieder so ein Wundermittel, was
berichtet wird, weiß nicht, ob du da schon was von mitbekommen hast. Das ist äh ein äh,
ja, eine medizinische, ein ein neues Medikament, was entwickelt wird in Israel, Israel, unter dem schönen Namen Exo, CD vierundzwanzig.
Das hat äh befindet sich gerade in der Phase eins klinischen Studie, also
ganz am Anfang, wo es im Wesentlichen noch darum geht, äh die Sicherheit zu messen, et cetera. Wir erinnern uns, also auch äh weiß ich, inwiefern diese Phase eins jetzt bei Medikamenten genauso vergleichbar ist, wie diese Phase eins.
Mit Impfstoffen, das nochmal bisschen was anderes, aber auch hier gibt's definitiv mehrere Phasen, die abgeschlossen werden müssen. Das heißt, es ist.
Lange nicht an dem Punkt, wo man sagen kann, man hat hier irgendwas bewiesen und man hat hier irgendwas äh erfolgreich zeigen können.
Trotzdem gab's relativ viel Aufhebens darum
besondere natürlich in der israelischen Presse, die das alles gefeiert hat als ein neues Wundermittel und ich dachte mir schon so aha, was ist das denn? Klingt ja interessant
hat mir das mal ein bisschen genauer angeschaut, ist jetzt mal wieder viel Biologie, die man irgendwie verstehen muss, die ich natürlich eigentlich gar nicht verstehe, aber ich versuche noch ein paar zusammenzufassen, was ich davon
mitgenommen habe, weil,
Das Besondere ist hier, dass es sich einfach mal um einen neuen oder anderen Ansatz handelt. Also alle Medikamente, die bisher so geprüft wurden und das allermeiste ist ja bisher dadurch,
ist ja eigentlich durchs durchs Gitter gefallen.
Bis auf so ein paar Sachen, die halt in manchen Momenten wirken können, wir hatten das hier schon mit dieser Anti, mit diesem Antigen äh Medikament, was halt zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt äh helfen kann, bevor eine Infektion schon stark um sich gegriffen hat,
Hier geht's jetzt um ein Medikament, was gegeben werden kann äh bei schweren Verläufen.
Und äh ja, warum alle so aufgeregt waren, war das in dieser Phase eins, Stufe, in der das ist, sie äh dass bei dreißig Patienten ausprobiert haben.
Die also ganz schwere Verläufe hatten und so auf dem dem Weg zum zum Sterbebett, äh diesen Weg zum Sterbebett im Prinzip schon angetreten,
die, was weiß ich, ganz schwere Atemprobleme hatte und so weiter, ist im Einzelnen nicht angeschaut, hab zwar so ein Video gesehen, wurde mit den Leuten gesprochen wurde, die waren natürlich alle ganz begeistert,
weil er eben dieses Medikament ihnen offenbar.
Vielleicht hätte helfen können. Das ist ja so die Sache, ne? Also denen ist das Medikament gegeben worden und danach ging's eben nach drei bis fünf Tagen richtig gut.
Das heißt natürlich jetzt nicht, das lag an diesem Medikament, weil das kann man mit so einer Studie nicht belegen, sondern da muss man halt,
mehreren Leuten das Medikament geben und anderen Leuten das Medikament nicht geben und dann die Ergebnisse vergleichen. Doppelblindstudie et cetera,
Nichtsdestotrotz macht es so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob's helfen konnte. Und deswegen habe ich mir das mal angeschaut. Und das Ding heißt Exo, CD vierundzwanzig, weil.
Hier Exosome zum Einsatz kommen. Hast du das schon mal gehört.
Ja ähm ist eine bestimmte Art von Stoffen äh.
Genau.
Immunsystem ja so dazu.
Art von Stoffen im System. So kann man das sagen. Und zwar und Exosome äh sozusagen.
Äh Transport
Hüllen kann man sagen. Also das ist etwas, was Zellen für die Hinterzellulare Kommunikation benutzen und also hier quasi Stoffe in andere Zellen machen, indem sie sie auch so umhüllen
Also so ein bisschen so ähnlich wie auch so das Virus unterwegs ist, ja? Das kommuniziert sich ja
selber in die Zelle, aber so können halt auch Zellen anderen Zellen Nachrichten schicken sozusagen. Also tatsächlich auch mit RNA.
Aber nicht nur mit RNA. Also diese Exosome sind solche Wunder äh äh Mittel, die halt irgendwie die Kommunikation,
Körper aufrechterhalten und so, ne? Und CD vierundzwanzig ist halt ein spezielles Protein.
Und in dieser diesem Medikament wird halt so ein Exosom genommen und äh um dieses Protein ergänzt. Also man nimmt halt so ein Exosom und
implantiert dem dieses CD vierundzwanzig Protein und dieses CD vierundzwanzig ist halt so 'n tausend Sasser im Körper
der,
unter anderem auch in B Zellen und T-Zellen und auch in vielen anderen Immunzellen äh vorkommen, ne? Aber auch in äh Muskelzellen et cetera.
Und in ähm BZ äh kann es halt ähm Teezellenproduktion stimulieren,
unter anderem. Und äh also es hat sozusagen eine Auswirkung,
auf das Immunsystem, ist nicht die einzige Auswirkung, die es haben kann, spielt auch eine Rolle bei
Tumorzellen und dieses Medikament wurde wohl auch ursprünglich als Mittel gegen Krebs äh entwickelt, also konkret gegen gegen Eierstock
Krebs, soweit ich weiß und ist halt irgendwie so ein, also eigentlich so ein Entzündungshemmer,
und auf jeden Fall äh das verstehe ich auch alles nur so im Ansatz. Dieses Medikament benutzt also sozusagen jetzt Exosome, um dieses Protein, dieses CD vierundzwanzig Protein direkt in Lungenzellen zu transportieren.
Also bei den Leuten wurde das quasi so äh eingeatmet oder reingesprüht, dass sie das also einatmen sollen, damit,
eben möglichst schnell in Richtung Lungenzellen gerät und diese Exosome transportieren dann quasi dieses Protein in diese Lungenzellen und
bewirken dort ähm Funktionen. So und äh die Funktion von die man,
die man sich hier verspricht ist, dass äh dieser Zytokinsturm unterdrückt wird, also diese Überreaktion auch des äh Immunsystems, das hat sie ja vorhin in deinem längeren,
Bonolog auch ein bisschen äh mit angesprochen, wie das an sich funktioniert und das ist ja so ein besonderer äh besonderer Umstand.
Neunzehn Erkrankungen, das eben auch passieren kann, dass der Körper einfach überreagiert, dass das Immunsystem einfach total durchdreht und irgendwie alles äh versucht zu vernichten, was bei drei nicht auf den Bäumen ist, was dann eben
entsprechend negative Auswirkungen hat und diese schweren Verläufe nochmal so richtig schön tödlich macht.
Also insofern klingt es für mich äh erstmal plausibel und auch der Punkt,
nur sagen, dass es sagen auch zu einem relativ späten Zeitpunkt noch wirksam ist, spricht.
Dafür, dass es dann eben diese, ja, überschießende äh Immunantwort, wenn dann das angeborene Immunsystem äh da los,
wenn es erworbenen Immunsystem dann losfeiert, äh, dass es dann sagt, Moment, Vorsicht, Vorsicht.
Irgendwie jetzt ja nicht nicht so heftig. Ich äh äh ja, mach mal, mach mal langsam. So und äh ja.
Kann man sich Videos so anschauen, gibt's äh diverse Artikel, ist auch alles verlinkt. Äh ich hab's aber auch vor allem deshalb jetzt hier erwähnt, nicht um irgendwie das neue Wundermittel auszuloben
einfach nur mal drauf hinzuweisen, ja es gibt auch jetzt viele Berichte da drüber aber Phase eins. Also da ist noch gar nichts ähm.
Überhaupt nichts klar und dementsprechend muss man das auch erstmal noch etwas zurückhaltend bewerten.
Aber zumindest ich sag mal plausibel klingt es für mich erstmal im Gegensatz zu ich sag mal anderen Therapien die da immer hochgekommen äh sind.
Dass dann eher zweifelhaf.
Genau.
Ja und die zweite Sache, die werdet ihr sicherlich auch mitbekommen haben. Das ist halt auch mal das.
Das ist schon tragisch, finde ich, also Universität Hamburg hat eine Pressemitteilung rausgehauen.
Und damit eine Studie
auch noch weitere Aufmerksamkeit gegeben, eine sogenannte Studie muss man dazu sagen, ja? Schon mit dem Titel, breit angelegte Diskussion als Ziel, Studio
zum Ursprung der Korona Virus Pandemie veröffentlicht. Und das ist halt wirklich so ein Moment, wo man, glaube ich.
Auch mal die Integrität von solchen Universitätsleitungen in Frage stellen muss, was die eigentlich manchmal so reitet, ne? Also die haben äh
ordentlich Gegenfeuer bekommen. Ich werde auch gleich erklären, warum sie da so viel Gegenfeuer bekommen haben bei dieser äh Studie. Das Ganze ist eine Veröffentlichung
von einem Professor an dieser Universität mit dem schönen Namen Wiesendanger,
oder wie sind Anger, das weiß ich nicht ganz genau, Roland Wiesendaner, der irgendwie nanowissenschaftler ist, also,
Kein Virologe und.
Der mal so kurz äh zusammengefasst äh halte ich die These raushaut, das Virus wurde aus dem wurde im Labor, in Wuhan äh.
Kinetisch erzeugt und von dort in die Welt gebracht. Also überhaupt gar keine Neuigkeit, sondern quasi so die Verschwörungstheorie von Tag eins an,
hier nochmal schön zusammen gefegt und das Ganze noch mit Studie und Pressemitteilung der Universität Hamburg rausgehauen und äh wie kaum anders zu erwarten war, Tag später
dicke, fette Meldung in der Bild-Zeitung deutscher Professor sicher. Corona war Laborunfall in China.
Schön groß, sechshundert Hinweise. Erste Infizierte war Forscherin in Wuhan, auch deutsche Geheimdienste ermitteln. Oh Mann.
Da weiß man mal wieder warum man einfach äh Leuten lieber Springer arbeiten irgendwie mal klar machen muss, dass sie sich mal ihren, dass ihren Job wechseln sollten, da einfach mitzumachen ist.
Einfach mal vollkommen unangemessen. So, jetzt haben sich das so verschiedene äh angeschaut, auch die Tagesschau hat's schon mal darüber berichtet und mal kurz zusammengefasst
kaum Belege für Labortheorie, also das ist halt einfach der Typ ist kein Virologe und die Quellen, die er da benannt hat, sind auch höchst fragwürdig
worauf ich jetzt im Einzelnen mal kurz eingehen will, um das mal abgehandelt zu haben, ist vor allem ein Statement, was ich bin besonders bemerkenswert fand von dem Projekt, was ich hier auch schon erwähnt habe, nämlich den Corona Virus
das waren die mit dieser ähm neuartigen Visualisierung des Virus, wo ich einen Vortrag von der Andrea Torn verlinkt hatte.
Und äh das fällt sozusagen voll in ihren Bereich rein, weil ja sozusagen diese Annahme, das Virus sei im Labor ähm.
Durch Labortechnik erzeugt, ja? Also künstlich hergestellt oder zumindest modifiziert, fällt sozusagen genauso in diesen Analysebereich rein, weil die schauen sich ja wirklich dieses Virus auf.
Proteinebene, also wirklich Kette für Kette an,
So, ne? Das ist das, was sie machen, sie modellieren das und versuchen ganz genau strukturell herauszufinden, wie funktioniert das eigentlich,
was, was, was, was können wir da gesichert feststellen, aus welchen Proteinen setze ich zusammen, wie funktionieren die, was machen die, was bedeuten Mutationen et cetera.
Na ja und die haben auf jeden Fall äh darauf Stellung bezogen, nicht zuletzt deshalb, weil sie auch an der Uni Hamburg angesiedelt sind und total,
äh
Not im News waren. Genau, das könnte man sozusagen sagen, ne? Also, ich will das jetzt hier nicht in der vollen Länge wiedergeben, aber vielleicht mal zusammenfassen, was sie eigentlich im Wesentlichen festgemacht haben. Sie haben also jetzt verschiedene Thesen, sechs Thesen von diesem,
dieser sogenannten Studie äh hervorgestellt und versucht dem
etwas entgegen zu halten, so. Erste These, Unkenntnis des Zwischenwirts belegt, dass es sich nicht um eine Krankheit
tierischen Ursprungshandel, ja?
Da sagen sie einfach, ganz klar, ja das einfach mal äh überhaupt nicht äh ungewöhnlich und äh auch bei Saas und Mers hat man das erst Jahre später festgestellt, was da so die Zwischenwirte waren.
Ist er so würde ich sagen die klassische ähm ja Appsonce of Evidence is not everydence of Epsonce falacy.
Kann man's auch sehr schön zusammenfassen, genau. Ja, ne? Also nur, wenn man jetzt irgendwas nicht belegen kann, äh heißt es noch lange nicht, dass dadurch irgendwas äh.
Das dadurch belegt ist, dass es das nicht gibt.
Genau. So. Also es kann sehr wohl einen Zwischenwert geben und äh bei Saaß hat man das später festgestellt, auch beim Meers wusste man erst später, dass es die Kamele waren und so weiter.
Zweite These saß ist ja so toll angepasst an den Menschen, dass es nicht natürlich entstanden sein kann.
Ja, das hat mich dann sofort provoziert äh sozusagen zu dem Wort Intelligent Design.
Es ist doch diese ist doch die selbe Nummer nach dem Motto oh.
Es ist so toll.
Ist so toll.
Es muss sich einer ausgedacht haben.
Von irgendeinem göttlichen Wesen oder in dem Fall von von Menschen ja.
Hierzu Inside äh Corona, das sei also totaler Unsinn, das äh kommt erstmal bei anderen Corona Viren,
auch vor und auch HIV, Influencer und Emola Virus sind alle extrem gut angepasst und da meinen sie halt auch gleich der Typ hat einfach mal keine Ahnung von Virologie und schreibt jetzt hier irgendwie aus seiner Position heraus, ne.
Ja. Also mehr dazu vielleicht ähm,
Also wenn man sieht, was die Natur so alles hervorgebracht hat, also fängt schon mal damit an,
dass in unserem genommen äh ich weiß nicht, ob du das wusstest, äh ist mehr virales Material
mit drin als jetzt kodierendes Material, das uns zum Menschen macht. Ich mein irgendwie neunzig fünfundneunzig Prozent wie unsere DNA ist ja sowieso nur irgendwie Müll und,
sagen durch früheren Virenbefall, wo dann eben auch die Samenzellen befallen wurden, haben es ganz viele Viren geschafft, sich auch in unser Erbgut hineinzumogeln, Erdbutmäßig, so damit fängt's dann schon mal.
So und dann ähm wenn du anguckst, was die Viren halt mit dem Immunsystem machen, was ich vorhin, also ähm.
Nur ganz ganz kurz mit dem um sich auch vor dem erworbenen Immunsystem zu verstecken,
So sorgen sie erstmal dafür, dass die Warnungen, die normalerweise außen an der Zelle angebracht,
werden so das Warnschild, ich bin krank, dass sie sagen, diese Warnschilder diese Warnschildproduktion lahmlegen. Aber das Immunsystem ist.
Nicht blöd beziehungsweise hat daraufhin wiederum Mechanismen entwickelt, die nach Zellen suchen, die überhaupt gar keine Warnschilder seit Längerem angebracht haben und killt die auch, weil es davon ausgeht, dass die halt irgendwie,
Liebe äh das da die Warnschilder unterdrückt werden und deswegen haben die Viren dann aber wieder eine Fake Warnschildproduktion,
angeworfen.
Und sozusagen Regenhalte, die Fake-Warnschilder an, damit sie halt nicht weggeräumt werden, ja. Also so äh ausgefuchst
ist äh äh der der Kampf zwischen jetzt Viren und Immunsystem so. Und ich würde eher sagen.
Ja wir wissen so viel einfach noch nicht.
Und das ist derart Komplex, dass ja ich einfach mal sagen würde, dass das
ja, dass das auch jenseits unserer Fähigkeiten liegt, so geile Viren zu designen, wie das Corona-Virus, ja. Und äh wenn dann hätte man's wahrscheinlich auch anders gemacht.
Die Idee wäre man gar nicht gekommen, ähm einen Virus zu machen, äh was halt.
Ja eigentlich schlechter ist als andere Viren und durch Weglassen plötzlich besser geworden ist. Also ich weglassen dieser ganzen Bekämpfung der Angeborenen äh äh Bekämpfung der Erworbenen Immunantwort,
Egal, weiter, äh, weitere Thesen.
Dritte These der Studie ist äh Fledermäuse fliegen ja keine zweitausend Kilometer weit,
Ja, also das ist sozusagen äh diese diese These mit dieser Markt in Wurhahn ist ja zweitausend Kilometer von den nächsten Stelle entfernt, wo man überhaupt nennenswerte äh Fledermausvorkommen hat.
Ja also abgesehen davon, dass es äh das Virus ja nicht unbedingt von Fledermäuse. Also man weiß zwar oder man sagt, also die Wissenschaft ist der Auffassung, dass dieses Virus schon.
Ursprung in Fledermäusen gehabt hat. Weil Fledermäuse generell Virenhorte sind, ja, deren Immunsystem ist in der Lage, so mit mit Viren so entspannt umzugehen, weil die gegen nichts überreagieren,
aber auf der anderen Seite sich auch eben von nichts so richtig aus der Spur bringen lassen,
anderen Umgang damit, das sind Tiere, die schon seit äh ja Millionen zu Tausenden,
äh dicht an dicht kalten Höhlen hängen, ja, die optimale Bedingung für die Ausbreitung von solchen Corona-Viren.
Ja, aber die kommen damit halt trotzdem klar. Deswegen sind sie da der Hort, das ist halt so. Wir haben ja auch.
Unmengen an Viren in uns, die jetzt auch erstmal kein Schaden sind, weil unser Körper damit einfach klarkommt, die auch teilweise wichtige Funktionen vornehmen.
Plus plus vielleicht noch äh dazu, weil das war auch so eine Erkenntnis dieser Woche. Ähm.
So äh auf die Frage, okay, wie lange bleibt denn so ein, kann denn so ein Corona Virus im Körper bleiben? Und da unterscheidet man äh dann äh wiederum von Viren,
die äh die Fähigkeit haben, latent zu werden, sprich,
sich dadurch zu verstecken, indem sie ihre Aktivität einstellen. Die bleiben dann da, aber stellen halt die Proteinproduktion erstmal ein und werden dann erstmal nicht bemerkbar und kurbeln die dann irgendwann später wieder an.
Corona Virus kann das nicht so, der kann nicht Latent äh werden wohl, der produziert halt immer weiter. Ähm aber
Es gibt dann halt Teile im äh Körper, so die Bluthirnschranke so, das Gehirn, die Augen und noch ein paar andere Organe äh Fortpflanzungsorgane, die halt ähm vom Immunsystem quasi mit einer Firewall,
getrennt sind
wo der Körper dann sagt, okay, da bin ich mal vorsichtig mit dem Immunsystem ranzugehen, weil äh so da richtig halt mehr Schaden als
Nutzen an, wenn ich jetzt anfange, keine Ahnung
ja am Auge irgendwie jetzt mit meinen mit meinen ganzen Antikörpern zu hart ranzugehen so und,
da kann wenn der Virus aber sagen erstmal diese Schranke auch überwunden hat, kann der da halt auch überdauern, weil in bestimmten,
eben Organen, die Immunreaktion nicht so krass ist, aber ja, das nur am Rande.
Genau, also aber diese These mit, sie fliegen jetzt keine zweitausend Kilometer weit, ja? Da kann man halt einfach nur sagen, also erstmal muss ja dieser Markt auch nicht unbedingt der Ursprung sein. Das ist der ein Ursprung, dass der der erste Ort, von dem wir Kenntnis haben, wo es sich ausgebreitet hat, aber das heißt ja nicht,
dass das auch wirklich der Ort ist, von dem es irgendwie erstmalig zwangsläufig ausging. Sondern es kann ja auch irgendjemand dahin gegangen sein.
Das kann einfach der erste Supersprayer gewesen sein, der da aufgetaucht ist.
Und wie schon erwähnt, andere Zwischenwirte sind ja auch möglich, also These mit diesen Fledermäusen ist auch so an den Haaren herbeigezogen
These vier in Wuhrhahn wurde an Viren als Biowaffen geforscht. Jetzt geht's richtig schön in den Verschwörungsbereich rein, ja? Dazu stellen sie halt auch nochmal fest, ja Forschung hat es dort gegeben, dass es irgendwie äh super Sofisticated äh Virenlabor da in Wuhan das irgendwie eins von zweien, die überhaupt
so nennenswert ausgebaut sind und äh vor allem haben sie dort halt eben konkret auch an der Nachvollziehung des Saarsausbruchs geforscht,
Und äh die ganze diese These, ja, dass das sozusagen als Waffen eingesetzt wird, weil
quasi damit experimentiert wurde, das Virus zu modifizieren, um zu gucken, wie es sich eben bestimmten Dingen verhält, ne? Ist vollkommen an den Haaren herbeigezogen. Abgesehen davon gab es auch entsprechende Forschungen äh auch in USA in in einem Labor in Norst
Carolina und wenn man sozusagen nur danach geht, was diese Institute an sich machen, müsste man jetzt alle unter Generalverdacht stellen.
Ja und machen auch eigentlich keine guten Waffen äh solche Viren.
Ja, das guckt nochmal mit dazu zu, dass das einfach Quatsch ist.
Ja, dafür dafür haben wir halt Antrags äh so eines ist viel praktikabler, das ist nicht ansteckend äh von
halt nicht von Person zu Person übertragen. Eigentlich willst du halt als Waffe als Biowaffe was haben, was sich nicht so von einem wird zum anderen fortpflanzt, sondern was äh dich halt beim Ein
atmen krank macht und dich in kürzester Zeit äh aus sein Gefecht setzt.
Aber sie nicht weiter verbreitet.
Aber nicht nicht nicht weiter verbreiten, weil sonst sind ja deine eigenen Truppen dann äh äh sofort dran und kannst das halt nicht eindämmen. Also deswegen ähm sagen.
Es ist an sich schon mal Unsinn.
Ja nicht erstrebenswert äh als irgendwie Waffe.
These Nummer fünf, das virologische Institut in Wuhan war unsicher,
ja? Also es gibt diese Unterstellung, das äh wäre ja jetzt irgendwie überhaupt nicht ausreichend geschützt äh äh gewesen et cetera
das auch Quatsch. Also erstmal handelt es sich hier um ein sogenanntes Bio-Safety Level vier Labor, das ist die höchste Stufe, die es überhaupt gibt. Also die arbeiten mit Unterdruck
ja da kann sozusagen gar nichts rausgedrückt äh werden. Sie haben Luftschleusen. Alle Leute arbeiten Vollschutzanzügen, alle Abwässer werden thermisch und chemisch behandelt. Also da
das ist sozusagen dafür gebaut, dass da nichts rausgeht, weil die ja wissen, was sie da äh womit sie's da zu tun haben. Und die Videos, die er da verlinkt, das ist halt irgendwie.
Ob Skures, Verschwörungsmaterial, die also äh überhaupt nicht belegen, dass dass das äh also da werden Sachen gezeigt, wo überhaupt nicht klar ist, dass das sozusagen aus diesem eigentlichen Schutzbereich ist.
Vor allen Dingen, ja vor allen Dingen würde ich auch sagen, dass das eigentlich auch für die Frage äh ein total unerheblich
ist erstmal also ob da jetzt ein Labor sicher oder unsicher ist, äh sagt jetzt auch erstmal nicht darüber nichts darüber aus äh ob das jetzt irgendwie zur Verbreitung beigetragen hat oder
nicht, ja, das ist irgendwie eine Neben.
Aspekt, aber du kannst sowohl es kann sich sowohl jemand in einem super sicheren Labor infizieren, ja,
Finger gestochen, keine Ahnung und äh,
ja und selbst wenn das irgendwie wenn es äh umgekehrt dann Sicherheits gegeben hat, sagt es auch nichts darüber aus, äh ob.
Ja äh das da passiert ist oder nicht insofern äh ja.
Ja okay, wir haben's gleich These Nummer sechs, die Behörden haben im Oktober einen Laborunfall vertuscht, ja, also angeblich soll sich hier eine Wissenschaftlerin als erste infiziert haben.
Das Ganze basiert aber dann wiederum aus äh Untersuchungen
die vom Pentagon an, von einer privaten Firma auf Basis der Auswertung von Mobilfunkstandortdaten. Äh
durchgeführt wurden, ja? Gibt überhaupt gar keine konkreten Beweise dafür, also alles nur Vermutung und lose Schlussfolgerungen und keiner äh gibt diesen Bericht
eigentlich irgendwie nennenswert was an. Naja, dann wird noch allgemeine Kritik geäußert, das Ganze hat irgendwie,
macht überhaupt nicht den Eindruck einer wissenschaftlichen Studie tut es wirklich nicht. Also so, ich meine, wir wissen alle, wie Studien normalerweise aussehen. Das ist mehr so ein Word-Dokument, wo dann ähm,
stellen gelb und blau hinterlegt sind. Es sieht halt auch wirklich einfach schäbig aus, ja? Gut, das ist im Wesentlichen eine Stilfrage, zeigt,
bloß nur so ein bisschen, wie das irgendwie gelagert ist, aber wo es halt dann so richtig krass wird, ist halt halt welche Quellen er nennt. Und Quellen sind halt hier irgendwie private Kommunikation, Twitter, Posts
und vor allem sehr viel Inhalte aus dieser Alltrit Bewegung, eine sogenannte Studie aus dem
Umfeld von Steve Bennon äh verlinkt auf Artikel auf epochtimes. Das ist so
so ein äh Fall und Gong Nahe Poste, die in USA.
Äh auch extrem grenzwertig äh kommuniziert,
gibt auch eine deutsche Ausgabe davon, die es auch sehr afD-nah, hat extrem viel Exenophoben, Content und so ein anderes Hetzblatt, irgendwie Summit News ist dort auch äh verlinkt.
Das will man auch sich gar nicht anschauen, wenn man das sich mal anklickt, ist alles ganz furchtbar. Und die ganze Studie ist auch noch voll mit Widersprüchen, ne? Also
wird zum Beispiel irgendwo davon gesprochen, dass der erste Patient am ersten Oktober zwanzig neunzehn äh bekannt geworden wäre, ja, andererseits hast du es an einer anderen Stelle, dass der Ausgang der äh Pandimie durch diesen Unfall diesen angeblichen am sechsten oder irgendwo zwischen dem sechsten und dem elften
Oktober dann stattgefunden hat. Super, passt also alles ganz wunderbar äh zusammen. Ich denke.
Also.
Ist natürlich klar, was jetzt wieder passieren wird. Wir werden dieses diese Studie, die natürlich jetzt vom Mainstream-Medien äh unterdrückt wird.
Weil sie nicht in den Kram passt, werden wir jetzt irgendwie die nächsten drei bis zehn Jahre noch um die Ohren geschmissen bekommen
und äh die Universität Hamburg darf sich, glaube ich, hier mal ordentlich schämen, weil sich hinter diesem Argument zu verstecken mit so einer ja wird hier forschen ja alle irgendwie.
Unabhängig und wir wollen uns ja sozusagen als Universität nicht in die Forschung der Wissenschaftler ein äh einmischen.
Ja okay, gut. Das das sollte so sein, ja. Aber gar keinen Grund, dann so ein Dokument, was wir dich schon auf dem ersten Hinblick.
Irgendwie total fischi ist und von jemandem kommt, der in diesem Bereich überhaupt nicht arbeitet und der dann auf einmal irgendwie tausend Verschwörungslinks auf dem Internet zusammenfummelt, das alles in so ein Pamphlet zusammengießt und das Ganze dann eine Studie nennt, die keinerlei,
hinsichtigen Qualitätsansprüchen an Studien ähm genügt, die auch nicht,
Pierreview ist, sondern die nur auf äh Research Gate hochgeladen wurde, wo das halt irgendwie einfach mal erstmal so hochladen kannst. Ja.
Ja, ich ich würde sagen, da hat einfach die Pressestelle äh versagt äh der Uni, also sowas muss man dann halt auch nicht noch über den Presseverteiler schicken oder featuren.
Ja gut, aber das haben sie ja verteidigt. Das ist ja das Problem. Ja, also dafür sind sie ja schon schnell kritisiert worden und dann so, ja, nee, ich meine, allein schon der Text, mit dem sich das veröffentlicht haben, habe das ja.
Anfangs schon äh gesagt, das hieß äh hieß es, Moment, jetzt habe ich hier die Seite natürlich in diesem Moment äh geschlossen, wie heißt es da.
Breit angelegte Diskussion als Zielstudie zum Ursprung der Corona Viruspandemie veröffentlicht.
Das ist das Ziel einer Uni, breit angelegte Diskussion? Darum geht's.
Nee, es geht nicht um breit angelegte Diskussionen, es geht um Wissenschaft meine Herren und meine Damen, ja, es geht hier um um Belege und es geht um um die wichtige Beiträge und ähm.
Ja. Also Herr Wiesndaer, das war nix. Und ich muss sagen, ich finde es erschreckend, dass Leute in solchen Positionen.
In die Lage versetzt werden. Also erstmal sich dazu berufen fühlen, sich hier irgendwie wichtig zu machen und so ein Dünnpfiff abzugeben, der irgendwie auch schon seit einem Jahr durchs Internet geistert, wo wirklich echt nicht viel Neues drin ist,
Ist ja nicht so, dass er jetzt irgendwas Neues erkannt hat, sozusagen von so einem Zusammengeschreibse von Verschwörungstheorien und und und rechtsextremen Content.
Den er jetzt hier irgendwie sozusagen als Diskussionsanregungen in den Raum wirft.
Aber er hat sich nicht davon geäußert, wer denn jetzt die Updates gebaut hat, äh so die B eins eins sieben, Updates und irgendwie äh das Süda.
Nee, komischerweise äh steht da zu nichts. Tja.
Und so hm ja.
Das sind.
Ja, die Briten waren's bestimmt, die die.
Das wissen nur die Geheimdienste. Der Wiesendanger weiß es auf jeden Fall nicht. Na gut, das äh beschließt unser äh wöchentliches Update. Lang genug ist es ja geworden.
Ja
Womit können wir denn unsere.
Unsere Zuhörerschaft verabschieden ins Wochenende. Es ist schon soweit angebrochene Wochenende.
Ja äh wir meint echt eine kleine Zusammenfassung der Sendung. Ähm.
So die auch wieder so, ja, so mittellang geworden ist heute, aber ja, also.
Meine Zusammenfassung wäre, mh.
Es entwickelt sich alles wie erwartet und vorhergesagt. Hm.
Der Rückgang kommt langsam zum Stillstand. Wir,
werden wohl eine dritte Welle äh ab März nicht vermeiden können, so wie sich das gerade.
Politisch entwickelt ähm,
Nicht nur politisch, sondern in Kombination aus äh Politik und Epidemiologie. Ähm es ist nicht sichtbar, dass wir gerade wie Willens und bereit sind.
Der Pandimie irgendwas effektives entgegenzusetzen, vor allem halt den neuen Mutanten nicht. Äh die werden im,
März, also Anfang März wird P eins eins sieben die häufigste Variante in Deutschland,
sein, das kann man alles schon sehen. Ja, aber,
auf der Plus-Seite, um jetzt auf was Positiven zu enden ja sehr wahrscheinlich gibt's dann wirklich im September äh genug Impfstoff für alle,
wie es aussieht. Hoffentlich hält sich das Virus bis dahin mit Mutationen äh zurück äh und äh die Impfstoffe funktionieren äh noch. Die Südafrika-Variante ist noch.
Ja im niedrigen einstelligen Prozentbereich bisher, das heißt um die müssen wir uns,
in den nächsten Wochen nicht so viel Sorgen machen, aber langfristig muss man halt sehen, wie denn jetzt der Wettlauf zwischen äh ja, B eins eins sieben und der Südafrika-Variante oder,
für eine B eins eins sieben auch mit den anderen, mit den Mutationen äh aus Südafrika kriegen. Äh.
Werden sehen.
Genau und die Impfsituation ist eigentlich äh stabil, nicht die Impfkampagne, aber die ganzen Impf
Stoffe, es kommen immer mehr raus, sie werden immer verfügbar, sie wirken sehr sehr sehr gut und
Und äh es gibt interessante Entwicklungen im Bereich der Medikamentierung, der Krankheit
Jetzt müssten sich nur noch die deutschen Universitäten mal so ein bisschen äh am Riemen reißen und irgendwie ihre Schwobler aussortieren, das fände ich mal ganz angemessen, weil das ist mir einfach zu hoch die Zahl.
Plus,
also wo auch noch Potenzial und sehr viel Luft nach oben ist, wäre die Art und Weise wie wir das mit dem Tracking und Tracing äh machen, das halte ich halt,
für äh absolut ineffektiv und das kann man halt auch an einen der Zahlen äh.
Sehen, äh dass das ineffektiv ist und äh ja, kann das auch ausrechnen, warum das inh.
Genau und mischt euch ein, bitte in die Diskussion. Also ich weiß, viele haben unter so schwubelnden Familien zu leiden, da sind auch schon äh Freundschaften aufs äh Leben gecancelt worden, aber es ist auch einfach Folgendes klar.
Die große Mehrheit in dieser Gesellschaft.
Tut das Richtige, die große Mehrheit dieser Gesellschaft versteht, was die Fakten sind
große Mehrheit dieser Gesellschaft hat die Bedrohung als solche auch begriffen und verhält sich in der Regel auch richtig. Wir dürfen bloß nicht den Fehler machen,
uns von den viel zu lauten Minderheiten, die dazu noch von einer nach äh.
Discord und und und Streit äh strebenden äh Medienlandschaft, die irgendwie versucht, das für sich äh auszuschlachten, von der sollten wir uns nicht groß von der Spur abbringen lassen.
Das wäre so auch mein Wunsch, dass ihr auch da äh entsprechendes Wort erhebt, wo auch immer ihr Gelegenheit dazu habt.
Na und dann vielleicht noch als letzter positiver Ausklang ähm wenn wir denn nur wollten, könnten wir jederzeit innerhalb von vier Wochen das Problem in den Griff kriegen.
Genau. Und solange Korona-Krise ist, gibt's auch regelmäßig,
Podcast von uns dazu, den könnt ihr auch zuhören, dass ihr jetzt so schlecht auch nicht
Und wir werden auch nächsten Dienstag wieder unsere kleine Quatschrunde äh im Clubhaus machen. Corona Wickli ist äh immer am Dienstagabend so ab einundzwanzig Uhr am Start. Da könnt ihr euch mit einklinken. Ähm und.
Ja ansonsten freuen wir uns über eure Kommentare, äh bleibt äh locker, bleibt positiv und wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.